Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Andre.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Es weihnachtet sehr. Draußen nicht so sehr, aber uns ist schon ganz.
Ganz weihnachtlich.
Weihnachtlich zumut.
Uns ist sogar so ganz retrospektiv zumute.
Gar kein Weihnachten, ist doch vorher Weltuntergang.
So retro.
Ist vorher Weltuntergang. Ja, scheiße.
Ja. Das stimmt.
Letzte Sendung vom Weltuntergang.
Und wir planen hier sowas lächerliches wie einen Jahresrückblick, statt einen irgendwie Weltrückblick.
Weltzeitrückblick.
Ja, so sind wir. Ist nichts besseres einfällt.
Sind ja äh netzpolitische Rückblicke auf einmal total in Mode, ja, also bisher war man ja gewohnt, dass äh irgendwann mal Markus, ich weiß nicht, war das, immer Markus, der es gemacht hat, der ist im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, ne, äh das das große Cut und Paste äh äh Festival am Ende des Jahres macht,
Politikorg und nochmal so alles zusammenhaut, was in irgendeiner Form äh in dem Jahr dran war. Und jetzt äh sprang
ich glaube zuerst hinterm Busch hervor. Ich weiß nicht, so ganz unerwartet kam das wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht für die eingeweihten, aber an sich war das ein Novum. Äh ich hab's jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht
näher betrachtet, in welcher Form ist das erschienen, Andre?
Das ist so ein A4 Heft auch in Bund und Hochglanz und so, recht schick eigentlich.
Ja, wie dick ist das, kann man da ordentlich was mit beschweren?
Ähm das ist A4, so iPad ähnlich würde ich jetzt mal äh.
Also nicht so als Durstoper äh geeignet.
Nee, dafür sind's zu wenig Seiten und A4. Dafür ist es bunt.
Es ist sehr, sehr bunt geraten.
Ja, was heißt das?
Ähm hier warte, ich habe da.
Farben und alles äh alle links sind blau und unterstrichen.
Ja das ist einfach sehr, es ist sehr, sehr äh sehr gelungen und sehr ansprechend gestaltet, wie so ein, wie so ein Hochglanzmagazin
tatsächlich und sehr, sehr gut visuell aufgearbeitet
äh und steht damit in einem direkten Kontrast zu dem Jahresrückblick von Netzpolitik Org, in dem sich kein einziges Bild findet, dafür aber sehr viel gute Texte.
Das ist ein Buch.
Allreiz, bei Allrads gibt's keine guten Texte.
Doch bei der Eiweiß gibt's auch gute Texte, aber sehr wenige. Im Vergleich zu dem, also hier, ich kann dir das ja mal zeigen, also ich habe das ja hier ist jetzt nicht ein PDF, was ich dir am Bildschirm zeige. So, das ist ein ausgedrucktes Heft und ähm so sieht das halt aus, ne?
Das ist das Ding von.
Dinosaurier da abgebildet oder.
Und Bilder von den Autoren und Werbung von äh der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung. Es ist ein richtiges, schönes Heft, glaube ich. Und das äh hat offensichtlich wie viele Seiten.
Ja, das wollen wir jetzt wissen.
Natürlich wissen.
Wenigstens, das ist aber jetzt nicht.
Hundertzweiundvierzig Seiten um. So und das Netzpolitik Org ist ein richtiges Buch, welches auch als Buch bestellt werden kann.
Ein E-Book.
Das ist auch als als gedrucktes Buch, kannst du das bestellen. Und ähm das hat zweihundert wieviel Seiten? Zweihundert, zweihundertsiebzig Seiten.
Kann man noch bei Pirat Bay bestellen?
Genau, das kann man bei Pirate Bay bekommen.
Und heißt glaube ich der das Druck Ding.
Amazon und irgendwann, wenn Google und Apple die nicht existierenden Brüste nicht gefunden haben, wird das auch dort mal freigeschaltet, aber die brauchen für dieses digital etwas, keine Ahnung, was die da noch machen.
Also mit allen Worten es wurde Submittel, aber es wurde nicht ähm.
Noch nicht. Wir haben's noch nicht entdeckt. Aber ich habe auch kein iTunes. Vielleicht findet der Tim das sofort.
Ich bin schon unterwegs, gucken wir mal.
Hier so äh finden lässt.
In der Zwischenzeit kann man auf Netzpolitik ORG Slash Jabuch Minus zwanzig zwölf eben äh EPAP, PDF und andere Digitalformate downloaden. Ist jetzt auch im Apple Store.
Ja, ich hab's äh interessanterweise sogar schon runtergeladen, stelle ich gerade fest. Ach nee, Entschuldigung, das ist der von Iroids, äh äh das ist der von Iroids.
Und dann gibt's nur noch hier die digitale Gesellschaft, das ist es nicht. Also insofern äh muss ich mich gerade mal zurücknehmen.
Genau, also Netzwerk Jahresrückblick gibt's Eiweiß Jahresrückblick, das waren die beiden, ne?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt wüsste.
Und also zwei zwei in meinen Augen doch überhaupt nicht,
konkurrierende Publikation, weil nämlich dieses wirklich das so das ist so richtig schön für
Ich hab's zum Beispiel auf dem Weg hierhin nochmal so durchgeblättert, dann haben sie so schöne Zeitleisten drin und so vom vom Geschehen und so. Es hat wirklich so ein so was man so äh nebenbei einfach mal so ein bisschen drin rumblättern kann während der Jahresrückblick
Blick äh von Netzkritik Org dann wirklich äh also eher außer also die guten Artikel zu den Themen nochmal hat und auch viele neu geschriebene, die also rückblickend draufschauen und so.
Also im Prinzip zwei unterschiedliche Ansätze an dieselbe Idee, da stelle ich jetzt mal äh öffnet sich da mehr einem breiteren Publikum und versucht.
Eher in Prosa zusammenzufassen und Netzpolitik org eher im Detail.
Ich habe noch nicht beide gelesen, ähm bei konnte ich nur reingucken, ähm bin natürlich befangen, weil ich den Netzpolitik ORG ja hoch äh Jahresrückblick mit herausgegeben habe, ähm,
wir wir versuchen natürlich auch äh die breite Masse zu erreichen, inwiefern uns das gelingt ähm wird zu zeigen sein,
Wir haben nicht so viele bunte Bilder tatsächlich erreicht man da vielleicht nicht jeden, der gerne mal ein schickes Magazin in die Hand nimmt.
Ja, ich habe mir eh nur das E-Book geholt von das ist jetzt gar nicht so bunt. Nee. Nö.
Ne? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn das ein PDF wäre, durch die ganzen Bilder wäre das bestimmt so um die siebzig MB groß oder so.
Neunundsiebzig oder so, könnte ich mir fast vorstellen.
Dich eigentlich schon vorgestellt, Andre, oder müssen wir dich gar nicht mehr vorstellen? Ich weiß nicht. Du bist ja nun schon äh häufig Gast gewesen dieses Jahr. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht durchgezählt, aber ist ja schon fast Inventar.
Viermal oder so? Bin ich jetzt hier.
Ja und du hast auch dieses Jahr den großartigen äh hier nach oben auf eine Meisterskala.
Grundrechtseinschränkungen.
Genau. Uns.
Na ja, das strahlst du so aus, ne?
Andere Meister von Netzpolitik org.
Genau, es schreibt da.
Noch ganz kurz ähm.
Das Netz zwanzig zwölf in der Printversion vierzehn neunzig als E-Book vier neunundneunzig,
Ähm Netzpolitik Org Jahresrückblick als Buch neun fünfundneunzig und als E-Book ähm.
Drei neunundneunzig oder umsonst.
Oder umsonst nach eigenem Ermessen, ne? Wenn man die bei Amazon Kindle, also man kann quasi die Kindle-Variante drei neunundneunzig ist dann eher so Spendenteil, aber oder eben auf Pirate Bay äh entsprechend.
Plus Flette. Und komplett unter CC bei.
Also es ist CC. CC Bayern. CC bei. CCB mein Freund.
Muss man ja kaufen. Das sagt ja der Name schon, ne?
Das waren die äh äh Rückblicke der anderen und äh äh wir sind uns natürlich hier auch nicht zu fein, äh um auch noch zu versuchen selbst einen solchen zu
das heißt, wir werden in der heutigen Ausgabe nicht so sehr auf die letzte Woche äh blicken, sondern eben auch sehr viel mehr aufs letzte Jahr, was ja bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik im wesentlichen
eigentlich schon ein Rückblick auf alles, was wir hier bisher diskutiert haben, ist, denn wir haben ja nun gerade unser einjähriges auch erst durch,
Linus. Nicht wahr? Und äh wir dachten uns, man könnte ja mal äh äh die Sache so angehen, nicht, dass wir jetzt äh anfangen einfach die Clips aus anderen Sendungen reinzuschneiden, sondern,
Mal zu schauen, was waren jetzt eigentlich wirklich die beherrschenden Themen? Was,
Ähm ist da im Wesentlichen drumherum passiert, was,
sagt uns das jetzt alles und hat das eigentlich noch irgendeine äh Bedeutung beziehungsweise,
Wo geht die Reise hin? Ist das ein Thema, was man noch im Blick halten muss im nächsten Jahr? Ist das so eine der Sachen, wo wir schon im Januar wieder davon ausgehen können, dass sie uns um die Ohren fliegen,
Ich äh würde mal meinen, das ist jetzt so unser Ansatz, oder? Sind wir uns da halbwegs äh einig in der Herangehensweise,
dann äh können wir ja vielleicht mal uns auch gleich äh das erste Thema rauspicken und ich vermute mal, wir fangen bei A an.
A wie Acta. Acta war ja eines der der großen Themen des Jahres, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Auf, auf verschiedensten Ebenen.
Actor ist tot.
Das eigentlich interessant, ne, dass da wirklich äh etwas zu Fall gebracht wurde, wo wir selbst, ich erinnere mich, dass wir auch hier noch saßen, kurz äh äh bevor diese Demos,
angekündigt waren und meinten so, na ja, da geht ja bestimmt wieder keiner hin und so, so ein trockenes Thema und dann äh passierte es auf einmal ähm ich weiß nicht, was da jetzt im Wesentlichen für,
Verantwortlich war, aber die Welle kam ja interessanterweise aus Polen, ja, dass dort Demonstrationen anfing und man so das Gefühl hatte, oh Gott, jetzt hier äh brennende Mülltonnen
irgendwie ähm ist die YouTube-Generation, glaube ich, äh dort eingeschritten und hat einfach ihren Beitrag äh äh geleistet, zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo glaube ich niemand diese Gruppe wirklich
halbwegs auf der Liste hatte und siehe da, äh es ging ein Zocken durch die europäische äh Politik und die Begeisterung für dieses Abkommen.
Sank,
Schwanz sank äh innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Es war erstaunlich, dass mit äh anzusehen und äh es hat sich dann relativ schnell abgezeichnet. Nach ein paar Monaten, dass hier,
wohl für die Politiker da keinen Blumentopf mehr zu gewinnen ist mit dem Ding und äh so langsam, aber sicher traten alle einen Schritt zurück, bis einfach die Unterstützung aufm Level war, wo jedem klar war, da kommt es jetzt eh nicht mehr zu einem einheitlichen Abkommen,
Wieso hast du das wahrgenommen, Andre?
Ja ähm so ähnlich. Ähm ist ja schon eine ganze Weile jahrelang verhandelt worden. Wir haben,
versucht, darauf hinzuweisen, die ganze Zeit und immer nur unsere hundert üblichen Freunde erreicht, die wir dann auch auf der Demo in wann war das? Januar, es war kalt.
Erwartet hätten, aber durch eine Verkettung glücklicher Umstände,
natürlich auch Partnerorganisationen in anderen europäischen Staaten La Quadratur, die haben sich da ziemlich den Arsch aufgerissen und das komplette Europaparlament,
massiv mit allen gesprochen, waren bei jeder Ausschusssitzung mit dabei, wo sie dabei sein konnten, äh Pressemitteilungen geschrieben, das ganze Ding begleitet Edri,
und dazu gab's dann irgendwie die glückliche Verfügung, dass in Polen dieses Thema aus Gründen, die noch nicht abschließend mir erschlossen sind,
hochgekocht ist, da saß 'ne Parlamentarier mit Masken im Parlament und die.
Tausende Demonstranten, die bei Minusgraden auf die Straße zu diesem Thema gebracht wurden. Das war irgendwas mit urheberrecht, das freie Internet, YouTube,
durch unter anderem das Video ähm wurde dann wohl so die Gefahr gesehen, die wollen unser freies YouTube und Internet kaputt machen,
streiten, ob das wirklich so um Abkommen stand. Tatsächlich,
einige vage Sachen, was auch ein Problem war, da dann niemand so genau wissen konnte, ja was kommt dann jetzt äh wirklich? Und ein,
Bonuspunkt für uns war glaube ich auch diese ganze intransparente Prozesse neben das Abkommen entstanden ist. Also das war, glaube ich, auch für die Parlamentarier, die das dann im Endeffekt abgelehnt haben,
wichtig, dass die die ganze Zeit nicht wirklich beteiligt waren und dann am Ende so 'n Dokument vorgelegt haben bekommen haben, wo es dann nur noch hieß, frisst oder stirbt. Du kannst zustimmen oder ablehnen, weil es eben so ein internationaler Prozess war. Aber,
Wir haben's geschafft, im Juli hat das Europäische Parlament äh nach Zittern,
abgelehnt, womit das erstmal in Versenkung verschwunden ist und in dieser Form unter diesem Namen nicht wieder auftauchen dürfte.
Wo es dann natürlich andere Abkommen wie das Partnership oder das äh CETA,
Teilweise in einzelne Absätze kopiert haben oder so, aber die Zivilgesellschaft bleibt dort wach, gerade Lackquadrathöhe und auch äh,
Geist, gucken da genau drauf, dass hoffentlich die Sachen, die in Akta stehen, so nicht nochmal durchkommen. Hätte niemals gedacht, großer Erfolg für uns.
Ist Michael Geist.
Michael Geist ist dieser kanadische Professor, ich glaube Jura,
der über Jahre die ACDA-Verhandlungen ziemlich genau begleitet hat und die allerersten Leaks von den Verhandlungsdokumenten auf seinem Blog Michael Geister CI,
veröffentlicht hat und ich glaube noch eh wir das so richtig auf dem Schirm haben hat er das eben überhaupt begleitet. Er war ganz nah an dem Prozess dran
doch mal Einordnungen gegeben, wo welche Meetings sind und was dort genau,
jetzt verhandelt wird und eben die ersten Leaks, die für uns echt wichtig waren, weil das wusste ja niemand, was genau da drin steht. Jetzt wussten weder die Parlamentarier äh noch erst recht wir und,
so genau,
wer eigentlich von Deutschland in den Verhandlungsrunden beteiligt ist, aber da kommen wir dann vielleicht bei Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nochmal drauf.
Ja, du sagtest schon.
Irgendwie acta haben wir jetzt äh gestoppt, verhindert, aber äh es scheint so, als würde diese Idee weiterleben, ja? Aktas, äh Kinder, äh Schwester, Brüder oder was kommen jetzt? Ähm ist eigentlich,
traurig anzusehen, ne? Wenn man sich über irgendwelche welche Energie da tatsächlich rein äh gesteckt wurde und das jetzt vermutlich von politischer Seite dem Kind einfach ein anderer Name gegeben wird und gegeben, ne?
Ja, ist ein bisschen schwierig abzusehen, äh Fakt ist, dass die Interessen, die hinter Acta stehen,
Natürlich durch so eine Entscheidung ähm nicht sich in Luft aufgelöst haben, sondern dass es immer noch
große Player, Medienunternehmen, aber auch auf diesem Akt der Stand ja dann auch so was wie Produktfälschung und hatten äh Patente weiß ich gar nicht so ganz genau, aber noch mehr als Urheberrecht und Internet drauf,
und auch beim Thema Ulrich ist ja so, dass wir jetzt nicht plötzlich,
überzeugt hätten, dass das mit dem Internet einfach mal sie zu akzeptieren haben, sondern,
da wird dann vom, ja, die Politik hat vor dem Mob im Internet ist eingeknickt,
Wir müssen, wir müssen das jetzt nochmal in richtig machen, ohne die Fehler, die wir bei Acta gemacht haben, aber dann kriegen wir das auch durch, weil wir haben ja recht,
Also ist nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie die Revolution fertig ist und man mit bezahlt und alles ist gut. Urheberrecht äh ist noch,
das wird uns so zeitig nicht verlassen, dieses Thema äh auf den verschiedenen Ebenen, unter anderem auch auf internationaler Abkommensebene, dürfte da das ein oder andere wieder aufpoppen.
Ja, Urheberrecht war ja auch äh ein hartes Thema dieses Jahr auf vielen Ebenen und kam.
Ähm ja, so aus dem Nichts auch dann mit auf den Tisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das durch diese ActA-Geschichte ausgelöst wurde, ein bisschen.
Hatte ich so den Eindruck, das war jetzt nicht ganz ohne Zusammenhang.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht genau, was,
zumindest, dass also man kann, vielleicht kann man's rückblickend sich so so betrachten. Es ging ja im Prinzip los mit diesem Wutausbruch von,
Na, es gibt eigentlich verschiedene Erzählsträge. Einmal irgendwie Kino TO waren die Verhaftungen irgendwie schon im im Vorjahr, aber diese Prozesse fanden statt.
Also ist die Plattform, auf der einfach Filme so kopiert verkauft wurden. Ähm, Angeboten wurden.
Kino TO hat links zu Streaming Diensten gesammelt, wo du dann diese Filme anschauen konntest, was weiß ich, TV-Serien, äh Kinofilme, alles was Leute schauen.
Die haben nicht selber gestreamt.
Nee, das war ja immer so deren Verteidigung, dass sie nicht selber gestreamt haben. Die Streaming-Dienste, wo sie die Sachen bereitgestellt haben, gehörten ihnen aber auch.
Ja gut.
Ja, die hießen nur nicht Kino TO. Und ähm der, das Businessmodell war das Ding halt einfach von oben bis unten zu zu pflastern mit äh Online-Casino und äh irgendwie äh Pornowerbung, ja.
Und damit haben die vermutlich oder haben die relativ viel Geld verdient,
Also über diese Werbeeinnahmen, weil die Seite enorm beliebt war und haben dann einen nicht bezifferbaren Schaden,
Bei den Rechteinhabern. Ja, also die also den der ist halt mal nicht das kannst du ja nicht sagen. Die die meinen natürlich, das wären Milliarden oder Millionen, aber weiß man ja nicht genau. Aber auf jeden Fall relativ klar ist, sie haben kommerziell,
gegen das Urheberrecht verstoßen und damit sich eindeutig äh strafbar gemacht.
Ich glaube an der Anklage stand auch, dass die wieder öffentlichen Bekunden äh manche dieser Hoster, die dahinter stehen und die tatsächlichen Inhalte zur Verfügung stehen, auch betreiben würden und damit
Abodienste verkaufen von kauft den Premium Account und du musst nicht mehr erwarten oder.
Solche Scherze, ja.
Der Anklage.
Ja, ja, das, also da bin ich mir auch relativ sicher, dass das, dass das der Fall war, dass sie da äh.
Bandenmäßig war da auch noch so ein Wort, was so ein bandenmäßiger als.
Was auch immer das heißen mag.
Übrigens taucht da ein Artikel äh auf Netzpolitik, aus Kino, To wird Kino.
Hör mir auf.
Immer wieder in den Statistiken von den meistgelesensten Artikeln des Monats auf.
Kriege auch immer noch Kommentare dazu, ja? Also es war hat nicht lange gedauert.
Also hat nicht lange gedauert, bis das mit dem Internet und der Hydro halt so ist, dann.
Das waren wenige Tage, ja. Ähm und zwar ist das tatsächlich, glaube ich, wenn du Kino,
Also wenn du auf KinoTO gehst, kommt ja dieser schöne Hinweis, die Kriminalpolizei weist auf Folgendes hin. Diese Wellen äh wurde mehrere Betreiber, wurden festgenommen, diese Domain wurde beschlagnahmt und so weiter. Und was die Leute dann machen, ist vermutlich, sie gehen
zum Anfang zurück im Internet, also zu Google und und schreiben dann Kino TO.
Und dann kommt irgendwann dein Artikel.
Und dann kommt mein Artikel, meine ich, ja? Erstaunlicherweise.
Ja, weil du jetzt schwäbisch ins Internet.
Ach so, weil ich jetzt grade Schwede bin, kommt er nicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist einer der ersten Treffer. Aus Kinotheo wird Kino XTO.
Und da hast, habe ich jetzt regelmäßig äh auch heute noch kommen dann da pro Monat ein paar Kommentare rein, äh wo dann äh ich da, wo die Leute sich dann immer noch streiten, dass ähm,
Kino TO,
Ja nichts Verbotenes gemacht hätte, sondern ähm nur auf äh Seiten verlinkt, ja? Also es wird ganz so einfach ist die Sache da eben leider dann doch nicht gewesen. Die waren also doch schon äh.
Unterwegs.
Unterwegs die Jungs, ja.
Ja, ähnlich eingeschlagen, äh hat ja auch äh einen Polizeirazzier bei unserem Spezialfreund Kim Schmitz in äh Neuseeland.
Auch eine ähm Webseite äh mit etwas fragwürdiger Ausrichtung. Mega Upload dot com. So einer von diesen, wie sagt man das gleich? Aus der korrekte technische Begriff.
Poster oder.
Sharehoster, ja.
Ja, der ähm durch allerlei allerlei drum herum auch viel auf sich äh,
um sich auf sich aufmerksam äh äh gemacht hat, wie man's von Kim Schmidt so gewohnt ist, ja?
Wie kein Mangel an Selbstbewusstsein leidet, das muss man ihm ja auch irgendwie mal wirklich zugestehen, ja, ist also egal, was ihm widerfährt, er hält sich nach wie vor für den größten.
Er ist wahrscheinlich auch der größte, also rein volumenmäßig.
Das ist sicherlich auch ein Aspekt, der da mit äh reinspielt, dann äh gingen wir irgendwie alle davon aus, dass er äh äh kurz vor der Auslieferung nach Nordkorea und seinem frühen Ende steht. Zumindest in die USA
dazu kam es dann irgendwie nicht. Die ganze Sache hat äh eine Kehrtwende erfahren. Ähm.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, nicht genau die Details, aber es wurden diverse juristische Verfehlungen festgestellt.
Der hat mich nicht, hat sich nicht sogar noch der dollseelenische Premierminister bei ihm entschuldigt, dass er zu Unrecht von Geheimdienst überwacht wurde?
Also die haben die haben sich da wirklich eine, also ich meine, dieser Typ, ja. Also, okay, die sind halt auch offensichtlich,
sehr dämlich vorgegangen, aber sie haben ihn, haben sie ja irgendwie mit geheimdienstlichen
Ermittlungsmethoden oder auch unter Einbezug des Geheimdienstes da ausgespielt und ihn dann da an die USA verraten, dann sind's ja irgendwie mit dem Hubschrauber rein auf das Gelände geflogen, da da wurde ja irgendwann noch dieses Video gelegt
ne, wie die dann bei dem auf seinem Anwesen da gelandet sind und mit den Sturmgewehren da reingerannt sind, gab's ja dann noch diese Zeugenaussage, wie er sich dann mit der Flinte im Pennegroom versteckt hat da in einer Unterhose oder so. Äh das bist du ganz dramatische Situation.
Foto hätte ich ja gerne.
Wurde er geschlagen von dem Polizei.
Da haben sie ihn geschubst in seinem eigenen Haus und.
Sieht Beweismittel nicht mehr verwenden, also wie in unserer damaligen Sendung angeguckt äh angekündigt.
König des Internets haben sie geschubst.
Aber dann geht der Typ hin,
äh lässt seinen Anwalt da einfach mal aufräumen, ne. Dann haben sie mir seine ganze Kohle eingefroren, dann hat er erstmal irgendwie seinen Anwalt dafür sorgen lassen, dass er wieder an seine an seine Kohle drankommt, äh weil er ja den Anwalt damit bezahlen muss, deswegen hatte der Anwalt da wahrscheinlich auch einen Anreiz,
das schnell irgendwie zu klären. Und ähm inzwischen scheint es so, als würde er da die komplette neuseelische Justiz auseinander nehmen.
Ich meine, der Premierminister entschuldigt sich bei ihm. Die ganzen Beweismittel, die sie haben, da können sie eh alle nicht benutzen.
Der sitzt jetzt wieder in seiner Villa und äh.
Nicht, wenn also soweit ich weiß, sitzt der noch in Haft oder allenfalls auf Kaution. Also da bin ich jetzt nicht genau auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Wir äh wir neu, also der ist, glaube ich, nicht mehr in Haft.
Nee, der baut doch sein neues Mega.
Ach so, ja stimmt, klar, der äh ist wahrscheinlich ach so, ja, dann droht er jetzt noch, den USA mit einer Milliarden klare Klage äh.
Vorstellen, dass der Premierminister sich entschuldigt, wenn er noch im Knast sitzt, also es äh.
Seinen Tweet letzte Woche, als er gemeint hat, erinnert ihr euch an die ähm Kampagne? Ja, die haben alle meine Autos weggenommen und ich habe immer noch keine Anklage.
Ja, also äh auch wenn äh Herr Schmidt jetzt hier keine sonderliche Popularität genießt, äh äh Chapeau zumindest äh für die,
Für die äh abermalig zur Schau getragene Kaltschnäuzigkeit äh und diesen Stehaufmännchen ähm.
Modus, den er irgendwie einfach perfekt beherrscht. Das fühlt sich unglaublich.
Ist also du wunderst dich echt so, dass du dass du den nicht platt kriegen, ne? Weil immer wieder, dann haben sie, genau, hier äh genau, er darf jetzt, er klagt jetzt, verklagt jetzt Neuseelands geheimdienst, Polizei und Geheimdienst.
Und bekommt dann die Abhörprotokolle ausgehändigt. Also dat da bleibt's auf jeden Fall noch. Ähm das bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend und er kümmert sich ja darum, inzwischen seine neue Plattform da irgendwie aufzuziehen, ne?
Aber die Domain dann wieder weggenommen. Also, okay, der Typ, der bleibt uns erhalten. Man hat ja zwischenzeitlich echt gedacht, ich meine, wenn ihr den mit Sturmgewehren aus seiner Bude zerren, dann meint's ja echt mal so, okay, jetzt sind wir den los, ne? Aber ähm.
Was mir danach einfällt, ist die Pirate Bay bleibt uns auch erhalten. Nein, gar nicht so groß auf dem Schirm, aber da war ja auch dieser mega. Wann war das? Das war schon zweitausendfünf, zweitausendsechs.
Ja, schon lange her.
Verurteilung äh der Leute, manche, die jetzt tatsächlich in den Knast gehen, aber die gibt's auch weiterhin und,
irgendso eine Bastion im Internet.
Die haben ja dieses Jahr ähm ich glaube im März dann endgültig nur noch aufgestellt. Es war auf jeden Fall auch dieses Jahr irgendwann.
Nee, es gibt immer noch Turens. Aber das ist die Ankündigung gab's.
Sieht, gibt's immer noch teuren Fights bei denen?
Nee, Torrens gibt's da nicht.
Vorgestern das Hörbuchnetzpolitik hochgeladen und da gibt's einen tollen Fall von.
Ja, du kannst den herstellen, aber Pirate Bay gibt dir den nicht mehr.
Nein, nein. Oder? Doch, doch, stimmt. Es gibt tatsächlich Torens. Ja. Erstaunlich.
Also das ist auch Website oder wie hieß es im Titel?
Das äh ja genau, also äh.
Galaxy.
Ja, also äh was den Award äh betrifft, da ist jetzt Kim Schmitz nicht der einzige, äh der hier einen Antrag stellen kann, sondern da ist definitiv diese ganze Parade Community auch ganz weit vorn.
Was ich aber jetzt noch sehr viel bemerkenswerter äh äh fand, außer, dass diese Webseiten alle überleben und auch ihre äh Urheber ist es
dann auch diese Urheberrechtsdebatte in Deutschland so ausbrach, also dass sie auch auf allen Ebenen geführt wurde, äh sowohl parteipolitisch, medienpolitisch, in den Zeitungen, die Zeitungen,
eine,
Für meine Auffassung unfassbare Dünnhäutigkeit bewiesen in dieser ganzen äh Debatte, die ja letztlich auch äh dieser ganzen äh Diskussion ums Leistungsschutzrecht äh endete. Da kommen wir sicherlich noch zu,
grundlegende Annahme, aber also man hat einfach gemerkt, wie eingefahren die die Meinungen,
Äh sind und und wie wenig Bewegung sich bisher in dieser Debatte befand, beziehungsweise dass es einfach gar keine gab. Ich glaube, am Anfang waren auch alle erstmal total entsetzt,
dass man das überhaupt diskutiert. Ja, also es ist eine ganze Urheberrechtssituation, das hat er einfach so so einen großen Nimbus, der unantastbarkeit,
Das äh das schon viele als ein Frevel äh erachteten, dass man da überhaupt drüber reden möchte. Das war jetzt meine Wahrnehmung.
Wie wer äh.
Von den Zeitungen vor allem hier.
Dass man überhaupt über das Urheberrecht ah ja, ja, äh.
Man das also überhaupt in Frage stellt, ja weil das doch so ein heiliges Gut ist und und und überhaupt das
Beste, äh was es gibt und die freie Presse und die Freiheit und überhaupt und die Unabhängigkeit und der Qualitätsjournalismus. Und also diese ganze Selbstverliebtheit dieser Medienszene
dort äh voll zur Geltung
und ähm verstand es eigentlich überhaupt nicht, dass dass man jetzt daher kommt und äh so etwas in Frage stellt, wie das so ein Recht äh siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod noch Gültigkeit kam.
Was mich ja damals schon verwundert hat, ist, dass.
Also man muss das, glaube ich, genau in diesem Zusammenhang sehen, indem wir es auch sagen, so einerseits diese Verhaftungslinie, die ja so ein bisschen neben Schauplatz war und dann diese ähm diese Kampagne pro Urheberrecht, also das,
heben dieses Themas auf die auf die Tagesordnung. Uever-Recht wurde seit Jahren diskutiert, von allen möglichen Leuten
Seit Jahren sind die Leute hingegangen und haben gesagt, hier Urheberrecht äh muss man ändern. Ja, es hat sich eine ganze Partei gegründet, die sich irgendwann mal mit diesem Thema ernsthaft beschäftigt hatte. Inzwischen tut sie's noch nicht einmal mehr,
Ähm und die äh plötzlich heben die Zeitungsverlage oder die Medien TM,
dieses Urheberrechtsthema voll auf die Tagesordnung und knallen das auf die Titelseite. Das war vorher kein Thema, was irgendwie die gesamte Gesellschaft beschäftigt hat. Es gab Fernsehsendungen über die über dieses Thema, ja? Urheberrecht, Urheberrecht, Urheberrecht. Und
das haben aber tatsächlich in dem Fall denke ich wirklich die Verlage da hochgehoben oder die, die also es ging ja los mit ähm,
Sven Regeners in diesem Radiosender.
Ihr pinkelt uns ins Gesicht.
Ihr pinkelt und ins Gesicht und dann irgendwie eine Woche später oder was ging das nämlich dann los mit diesen offenen Briefen, ein,
Tatort Autoren und dann
Urheber, dann kam irgendwie zurück, wir sind die Bürger und dann sind kamen andere, wir sind aber auch Urheber. Und dann kam irgendwie noch so ein Aufruf, wir sind die Pfeil-Chara und äh
alle schrieben dann auf einmal dann einundfünfzig Tatorten und einundfünfzig Hacker und alle,
äußerten sich auf einmal zu dem Thema Urheberrecht getriggert, ursprünglich denke ich auf jeden Fall von Seite der Medien, weil es gab keine äh,
sage ich mal, außerparlamentarische Gruppe oder auch keine parlamentarische Gruppe, die sich irgendwie angestrengt hat, dieses Thema zu setzen.
Na ja, also ich glaube.
Außerdem rechte Inhaber.
Hat damit zu tun, dass äh die Piraten tatsächlich in einige Landtage eingezogen sind und man sich vorher mit ihnen nicht beschäftigt hat, weil man die Ehe als äh
Außenseite null Chance Spinnergruppe wahrgenommen hat und dann aber auch zeitgleich Anfang des Jahres diese Demos mit zehntausenden Leuten bei Minusgraden zu Acta,
Ähm ich glaube äh das sind so zwei Ereignisse, auf das dann diese Pamphlete und Reden von Element auf Urheberrechtsverletzungen und was das alles gibt. LSR auch ähm,
Reaktionen waren, um mal klar zu machen, nee, nee, hier, die wollen uns an unsere.
Nicht zuletzt acta. Also ich denke, dass Akte ist schon den den Ball.
Auch die Piraten, glaube ich.
Ins Rollen gebracht hat, ja, aber auch die Piraten hätten, glaube ich, diese Diskussionen nicht so aktiv aufgenommen oder es nicht geschafft, sie so in die in die in die äh Diskussion zu tragen.
Nein, nein, nicht, dass sie das getan hätten, nur dass sie dafür stehen mit ihrem Logo und mit ihrem Freiheit-Internet.
Ne? Wenn man erstmal geguckt hat, gab's dann auf einmal ganz viel, ne? Aber äh,
gut, das äh nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal zur Kenntnis, dass es diese Diskussionen gab und auch noch gibt und äh auch irgendwie noch lange nicht ausgestanden äh ist, also für zwanzig dreizehn sehe ich da schon eine äh Fortsetzung,
Auf breiter Front, weil sich das ja eben durch äh äh viele weitere Themen dann auch ähm durchziehen.
Das erinnert mich so langsam langsam so ein bisschen an äh Blogger wirst du Journalisten, also die Debatte gibt's schon ewig.
Ulrich sogar noch länger als Blogger versus Journalisten, aber irgendwie eigentlich hat man alles schon gesagt und dreimal durchgekaut und jetzt müsste man einfach mal irgendwie den kurdischen Knoten lösen und was machen.
Ja, es ist halt, wie man so schön sagt, äh schon alles gesagt worden, aber noch nicht von jedem.
Doch mittlerweile auch von jedem.
Ja
Sind halt Interessen, ganz klar.
Ähm Schultrojaner hatten wir noch.
Ja, also in dem Zusammenhang.
So zum Thema Urheberrecht ein.
Ja genau das spielt ja auch eine Rolle, also Schultrojaner,
War ja sozusagen diese wirre Idee. Man könnte ja mal Software installieren auf Computern in der Schule, die halt da die ganze Nutzung von Urheberrechtsmaterial äh äh überprüft
ja? So eine Spionage äh Software an Schulen, die einfach.
Auch ein ein unglaublicher Kniefall vor einer äh urheberrechtsinteressen Gruppe äh darstellt.
Ohne Not, wie ich finde. Auch der Schuhtrojaner hat es letzten Endes nicht überlebt.
Und ich denke auch das Projekt ist kann weitgehend als beerdigt angesehen werden, zumindest in, in, in, in der Form,
angedacht wurde, da am Schultrojaner, denke ich, sieht man auch noch sehr schön etwas, was.
Was ich in gewisser Hinsicht für ein Auslaufmodell halte, nämlich.
Nicht, dass das jetzt schon komplett weg sein wird, aber die letzten Jahre waren auch extrem davon geprägt, dass äh in der Politik so Initiativen gestartet wurden, die so dermaßen,
Weit weg von einer technischen Realität sind. Also,
Zensursular, war äh dadurch das größte Ding, aber auch dieser Schultrojaner
ganzen, ja, das lösen wir jetzt hier mit Überwachungssoftware, da braucht man doch nur so ein Windows-Programm und so weiter, also auch so diese diese Windows konforme Denke, ja, so äh alle PCs laufen unter Windows und wenn wir da für Windows eine Lösung haben, dann haben wir eine Lösung und so, ja, ich meine, das äh
verschwindet jetzt genauso schnell wie Windows. Ähm,
will nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt große Hoffnung dafür habe, dass wir künftig nur noch auf technisch kompetenter Ebene äh reden, aber es hat sich zumindest äh durchgesetzt, dass wir ähm oder dass,
auch in den Parteien zunehmenden Maße die eigenen Experten gesucht und teilweise auch gefunden werden. Ja, also das Debatten,
Zumindest mal von Leuten begleitet werden, die auch schon mal selber einen Computer eigenständig ein und wieder ausgeschaltet haben und nicht dafür auch noch den Assistenten bemühen.
Thema Urheberrecht. Ich glaube, wir können dann, wir können da noch viel mehr zu sagen, oder? Also, wollen wir schon zum Leistungsschutzrecht oder wollen wir uns noch ein bisschen mit der GEMA auseinandersetzen?
Ja, ich meine, die ganze GEMA-Debatte war ja dann die nächste äh Detaildebatte, die ähm da ähm.
Sich sich anschloss an die gesamt äh Geschichte und ja, das äh hat ja sehr breiten Raum eingenommen.
Das war sehr bereit, ne? Erst haben sie sich irgendwie dieses Jahr mit YouTube da irgendwie weitergezofft, obwohl sehr schön, was sie auch schon seit Jahren tun. Dann wollten sie sich mit den Clubs anlegen. Dann gab's noch die Petition gegen die Gamer Vermutung.
Dann haben sie in diesem Jahr noch die Hausdurchsuchung bei den Leuten gemacht, ja?
Ähm.
Letztes Jahr bei Operation gehen wir irgendwie mitgemacht haben. Bei hundert Leuten in Deutschland ist die GEMA ja hat die Hausdurchsuchung veranlasst.
Hausdurchsuchung. Also.
Internet nicht gerade noch beliebter gemacht, als sie ohnehin schon sind.
Nee.
Also Dedos äh ist ja, glaube ich, dem den der geneigten Hörerin bekannt, dass äh lahmlegen eines Servers durch das massenhafte Aufrufen. Ähm in dem Fall,
glaube ich, die Webseite der GEMA ist jetzt nicht unter den Top ten der meistbesuchten Websites, das heißt also ein Ausfall der GEMA-Website ist ähm,
insgesamt äh zu verschmerzen. Wahrscheinlich hätten sie's gar nicht gemerkt, wenn äh nicht irgendwann mal einer auf Twitter geguckt hätte, was das alles auf GEMA ist da oder ähm ja und dann haben sie halt äh diese Leute,
mit hundertsechs äh äh Hausdurchsuchung, ja. Äh interessant, also das das muss ja mal überhaupt erstmal hinkriegen. Nee, Quatsch.
Doch, bei hundertsechs Beschuldigten Hausdurchsuchungen in Deutschland.
Tja, allein Eier.
Die gehen mal sehr omnipräsent in Deutschland, auch wenn eigentlich niemand sie kennt, aber durch dieses dieses Video ist in deinem Land leider nicht verfügbar, kennen mittlerweile sehr viele normale Menschen, die GEMA nicht gerade als Freund, unter anderem
virale Video des keine Ahnung, welches Superlativ kann man eigentlich nehmen? Äh Psy.
Gangam-Style.
Ist äh in Deutschland in deinem Land leider nicht verfügbar.
Das das äh habe ich nie so ganz verstanden, warum das nicht so ist.
Wegen dem Urheberrecht, Mann.
Und der GEMA, das muss uns beschützen.
Ähm genau, aber.
Und versus YouTube haben ähm,
eine Entscheidung vom was war das Landgericht Hamburg, ne? Der Klassiker äh bekommen, haben aber glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, bei der angekündigt in Berufung zu gehen, insofern
uns auch noch eine Weile bleiben, weil die die GEMA will natürlich nicht
der Buhmann sein und den Hass der ganzen Musiknutzerinnen und Nutzer auf YouTube auf sich ziehen, mischte aber andererseits Geld von äh YouTube, für die Videos haben,
auch eine Debatte, die uns leider erhalten bleibt.
Genau, wo man aber auch wirklich den äh nochmal betonen muss, dass die Gamer nicht YouTube zensiert.
Die GEMA einigt sich einfach nur mit YouTube nicht auf einen Preis. Und das ist also so viel zum Thema YouTube-Konflikt zu sagen und wie wie die GEMA intern die Kohle verteilt, ist halt steht auf einem anderen Blatt und ist auch nicht in Ordnung.
Auch dieses Jahr kam ja raus, dass es auf YouTube ein äh Rights Inhaber Interface gibt,
wo eben Plattenfirmen aber ich weiß nicht genau, nicht auch die GEMA,
ähm eben Zugriff haben und Videos, von denen sie meinen, die Rechte zu haben, was auch nicht immer äh hundertprozentig funktioniert, eben sperren können, dann mit der äh Meldung,
wegen der GEMA.
Da gab's aber auch ein ähm,
Ein Urteil dieses Jahr und das war, glaube ich, auch genau dieses YouTube-Gema in dem gesagt, wo das YouTube da noch mehr unternehmen müsste, um um da in äh eine Umgehen dieser Sperre irgendwie zu verhindern, ja.
Und dass die dass dass sie quasi aktiv selber nach Content suchen müssen, den sie,
der ihnen schon mal gemeldet wurde, das heißt, dass nicht jeder einzelne Link von dem Rechtinhaber gemeldet werden muss, sondern dass sie auch selber was tun, was sie aber andererseits auch machen, ne. Sie haben ja dieses Content-ID-Verfahren oder was, mit dem sie versuchen, etwas worüber einmal
sich beschwert wurde dann auch in Zukunft.
Zu diesem Ding äh nahezu eine Sondersendung abgeliefert äh die zweiundzwanzigste, du willst es doch auch äh war ja weitgehend bestimmt von diesem Thema.
Okay, dann verlinken wir die.
So, womit machen wir weiter?
Wollen wir die Gamer nicht abschaffen? Oder wie ist.
Haben wir schon gesagt, wie es weitergehen wird mit der äh äh GEMA eigentlich, also das Thema bleibt uns auf jeden Fall erhalten. Da bin ich mir sicher, da geht noch eine Menge. Ähm gerade auch im Zusammenhang hatten wir die C drei S schon erwähnt. Äh äh genau, also dann macht das doch mal kurz.
Ja, es gibt die Initiative, die gehen wir zwar nicht ganz abzuschaffen, aber eine Alternative dazu zu gründen, die C3S Cultural Comments Collecting Society, eine Alternative, Verwertungsgesellschaft,
womit man eben auch einige Sachen, die bei der GEMA nicht möglich sind, wie GEMA-Mitglied sein und trotzdem eigene Inhalte unter freien Lizenzen veröffentlichen und so weiter und so fort.
Ähm die man damit machen können soll und ein großer Punkt ist natürlich auch die Gamer Vermutung. Äh das ist bisher ist, wenn ich ähm kommerziell Musik,
Spieler in meinem Geschäft Radio, Club oder wie auch immer,
dann erstmal davon ausgegangen wird, das ist ja wohl GEMA-Musik, außer wenn ich das Gegenteil äh beweise.
Resultiert unter anderem aus dieser, ja, hm aus diesem Monopol, das ist bisher eben nur genau eine Verwertungsgesellschaft, die GEMA gibt,
und die C drei S,
versucht, genau diese GEMA Vermutung zu kippen. Jetzt müssten wir den genauen Stand nochmal recherchieren. Äh es wurde immer wieder angekündigt, äh dass sich die C drei S gründen möchte. Gab dann auch ein Datum in Berlin,
kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, ob die schon gegründet ist. Fakt ist, dass das gar nicht so einfach ist äh und dass da jede Menge juristische Hürden äh zu bewältigen sind.
Ja, vor allem muss er da auch erstmal finanzieller ähm Punkt erreicht werden, wo sie genug Mitglieder oder zumindest Förderer hatten
Um die notwendige Kohle zusammenzubringen und dann sich dann auch wirklich anerkennen zu lassen, damit ja auch definitiv eine Alternative zur GEMA darzustellen. Also allein die Existenz dieser Organisation könnte dazu führen, dass diese GEMA-Vermutung
entfällt, da es ja sozusagen eine andere Organisation gibt, die eben auch Rechtevertreter spielen möchte und deswegen,
dann zumindest schon mal zwei zur Auswahl und damit wäre dieser diese wie der Techniker sagt, äh wäre sozusagen dahin. Das ist,
unklar, ob das gelingen kann und wird, aber es bleibt spannend.
Gleichzeitig gibt's noch die Petition gegen die äh geben wir Vermutung, ne. Die hat ja auch ähm,
das Quorum erreicht mit über fünfzigtausend äh Zeichnern. Insgesamt zweiundsechzigtausendachthundertzweiundvierzig. Ähm und da wird's also dann noch die die allseits beliebte Anhörung zu geben. Aber Petition haben wir, glaube ich, nochmal in,
ein eigenes Thema, was die Petition dieses Jahr angeht. Um noch beim Urheberrecht zu bleiben, welches uns ja als Thema erhalten bleiben wird, Leistungsschutzrecht, sollen wir da mal uns jetzt drüber unterhalten?
Ja, das war ja dann ähm im Prinzip,
Ausklang für dieses Jahr irgendwann steigerte sich die ohnehin schon hysterische äh Diskussion oder na sagen wir mal bis dahin war sie ähm emotional, überzogen,
anstrengend äh und ähm ähm na ja, so in dem Level fand ich bewegte sich die ganze Urheberrechtsdebatte bis dahin
Und mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht ist es wirklich so, in so eine totale Hysterie äh und völlige Überdrehtheit äh gegangen. Also da wurden dann auch die Fronten klargemacht,
und die Verleger mit ihren postillen und den Journalisten, die dort eben abhängig beschäftigt sind, feuerten irgendwie aus allen Rohren und das gab irgendwie kein halten mehr,
Seitdem habe ich auch wirklich das Gefühl, dass es so ein bisschen mit diesem Qualitätsjournalismus äh so weit dann wohl doch nicht her ist, wenn man sich da so ohne Weiteres instrumentalisieren lässt, aber vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur so.
Wie wir schon am Anfang feststellten, hast in dieser ganzen Debatte,
Fronten einfach so verhärtet sind, beziehungsweise das Selbstverständnis auch dieser einzelnen Gruppen so dermaßen überzogen krass ist, dass äh wir noch sehr weit von einer wirklich vermittelnden Diskussion,
entfernt sind, nicht? Wir haben da auch so wirklich krasse äh Akteure so auf der einen,
Extremseite der Herr Käse, ja, der äh Cheflobby ist da bei,
Beim Springer Verlag, der also wirklich äh enorm trommelt in der Öffentlichkeit für dieses sogenannte Leistungsschutzrecht.
Das ja im Prinzip möchte, dass eben die Verlage so einfach mal pauschal dafür, dass ihr Zeug,
Ähm verwendet wird im Netz,
um darauf dann zu linken, dass man dafür dann auch noch Lizenzen nehmen kann, beziehungsweise also Geld einnehmen äh können soll. Das wird da eben einfach quasi so auf einem Level von,
Selbstverteidigungsrecht genommen, ja, man wäre ja zu arm und klein und, und, und, und, und, und schutzlos, dass man eben ein Schutzrecht bräuchte, ja?
Der anderen Seite eben die bösen, bösen Suchmaschinen. Das ist so das eine Extrem. Auf der anderen Seite äh eben so die.
Äh der totalen Freiheit und alles muss irgendwie überall jederzeit äh verfügbar sein und es lässt sich,
Recht keinen Zwischenweg äh ergeben. Darin gefangen die Politiker, die mit vollkommen Wirren,
Initiativen versuchen da den Wunsch der Verlage zu entsprechen und das irgendwie in ein Gesetz zu gießen und keiner weiß eigentlich, was genau gemeint ist.
Aber ist also ich bin, ich ich bin irgendwie mit dieser emotionalen äh Interpretation, diese dieses Geschehnis ist gar nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich. Also ich finde, man kann da schon einfach offen sein, dass es,
Hauptsächlich erstmal um Geld geht. Da diskutiert keiner Werte. Da ist also.
Also ich denke, das kann man schon auf jeden Fall so diagnostizieren, dass da jetzt nicht darum geht, dass die Zeitungsverlage das für eine eine moralisch gebotene äh
äh Erweiterung unserer Gesellschaft halten, dass dass ihnen ein Leistungsschutzrecht eingeräumt wird, sondern die wollen einfach Kohle haben.
Das ist mir schon bewusst, das würde ich jetzt auch nicht in Abrede stellen wollen.
Also entsprechend und.
So so wird diese Diskussion geführt.
Aber in der Zeit, in der Zeitung steht, ohne Leistungsschutzgeld, ist der Untergang des Abendlandes, weiß keine Zeitung mehr gibt.
Ja
Google uns die Zeitung weggemacht hat. Die Google Taliban. Nee, aber also.
Weggegoogelt.
Ich finde es, ich finde es erschreckend insgesamt, dass das überhaupt.
Also was die, was die Verlage ja da Google dann vorwerfen, als Google sich dann mit einer Kampagne äh dagegen wandte, gegen diese gegen den Gesetzesvorschuss, dass die Verlage dann sagten, ja wir finden das aber ganz erschreckend, dass Google da seine Macht nutzt, um
äh für dieses Leistungsschutzrecht zu dominieren. Während die Verlage, das natürlich das gerade dieses Jahr, wir haben's ja schon behandelt, was die Verlage sich zum Urheberrecht geäußert haben
und wie was also wie Medien sich da für Urheberrechtinstrumentalisiert haben,
Ist natürlich auch sehr erschreckend, dass äh oder ganz besonders erschreckend ist, wie wie die da ein ein Thema gesetzt haben, aber dieses dieses Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ja, was ist damit? Es ist, es lässt uns fassungslos äh zurück, ja.
Es gibt einen Text, über den ich gestern stolperte, den hat Johannes Eber geschrieben, den ich ähm.
Den ich jetzt nicht wirklich kenne muss ich sagen. Ähm aber der hat einen schönen Titel und ich habe ihn dann nur so überflogen den Artikel, aber der der Artikel hat den Titel, welche Leistung, welcher Schutz, welches Recht?
Und das finde ich, das ist einfach so alles, was man äh,
und äh seinen Blog trägt den der Pixel Ökonom betrachtet das Leben aus dem Blickwinkel des Volkswirts,
Und das finde ich mal ganz äh ganz schön, den Artikel allein schon des Titels wegen äh lege ich dem geneigten, der geneigten Leserin natürlich auch noch als ans Herz.
Ja, ich meine, das ist auch noch jetzt eine der offensten äh Dinge überhaupt. Hier ist noch überhaupt nicht klar, was kommt. Wir haben ja hier auch äh äh glaube ich in unserer Runde verschiedene Einschätzungen der Sache, während ich immer äh mit dem Kopf schüttle und sage, das
Das ist einfach so albern, dass das das das kann es überhaupt gar nicht in Gesetzesform äh schaffen, weil allein so viel ähm,
Meiner Meinung nach, verfassungsmäßig schon dagegen spricht, durch diese unklare Formulierung und vor allem auch diese Vermutung, dass es sich hierbei sehr um so eine Lex Google äh handelt, ja, die dann allerdings äh viele andere Systeme mit äh als Kollateralschaden
eindämmt. Es gab ja auch äh oder gibt auch nach wie vor allgemein diese Vermutung, wohl auch von mir geäußert, nicht nur von mir,
dass Google ja am Ende einfach sagt, naja dann machen wir halt ohne euch machen wir einfach zu. Äh es gab jetzt ja gerade eine eine interessante,
Einigung in äh Belgien, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt.
Ja
Äh Google sich da mit den verlängern. Also da wo sie ja auch schon mal gesperrt haben,
Ja, dass sie sich da jetzt drauf geeinigt haben, so nach dem Motto, na ja, wir zahlen euch irgendwie zwar jetzt so direkt nichts, aber wir machen jetzt hier mal so eine gegenseitige Vereinbarung. Und zwar, wir schalten bei euch ein paar,
Anzeigen in euren komischen Blättern. Also wir verbreiten jetzt sozusagen die Google Propaganda auch äh da,
und dafür werdet ihr aber jetzt hier unsere Google-Anzeigen grün.
Ja, wobei man auch sehr schön sehen kann, wohin dieser ganze Quatsch einfach führt, nämlich in eine totale Bevorzugung letzten Endes, also Google,
kann da eigentlich nur müde drüber lächeln, glaube ich, weil am Ende ist rechtlich überhaupt nichts passiert, sondern sie hat quasi die ganzen Zeitungen als Kunden äh äh gewonnen, ja? Und dafür drucken sie halt noch ein paar Grundprints,
und machen dann halt auch noch da ihre Werbung, also es ist vollkommen äh irre, ja? Und.
Aber das ist genau das, was man, wo Kartellwächter drauf achten, genau solche Phänomene. Und also ich genau, ich bin ja äh wir können das ja jetzt mal, machen wir jetzt einfach mal. Ein einem Jahr treffen wir uns wieder an an servier Stelle. Ich sage,
Äh wie ich das echt sagen? Ja okay, also äh es geht ja nicht um Geld. Oder wollen wir auch also Geld, wie viel hast du dabei, Tim?
Wie jetzt schuldig dir noch was.
Sollen wir um Geld werden? Nein, nein, wir wetten jetzt nicht um Geld, darf man, glaube ich, gar nicht, ne? Nicht, dass wir also, ich würde, ich sage, Leistungsschutzrecht kommt.
Und äh Verlage versuchen dann die über Kartellrecht sich da reinzuzwingen und irgendwie eine Marke von Google rauszupressen,
und das werden sie versuchen und Google überlegt, ob sie's äh ob sie's machen oder nicht. Das wäre jetzt so meine,
Leistungsschutzrecht kommt nicht durch den Bundestag, du glaubst noch an äh an unseren Gesetzgebungsprozess, das finde ich gut, das ehrt dich.
Schränke es etwas ein. Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es nicht beschlossen wird,
Aber ich glaube, dass wenn es beschlossen wird, dass es so schnell in äh juristische Bredouille kommt, entweder durch eine entsprechende Verfassungsinitiative oder allgemeine äh Zweifel, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was da jetzt ähm,
juristisch überhaupt die Sache zu Fall bringen kann, also rein rechtlich gesehen zu Fall bringen kann,
aber es es wird einfach nicht in Kraft treten können oder wird da wieder genauso zurückgenommen, so wie beim Zensursalat.
Ja, da könnte ich mich damit anfreunden.
Das ist so meine Erwartung der Dinge. Was denkst du?
Prognosen sind schwierig, besonders wenn sie die Zukunft betreffen, vor allem da da so viele äh Variablen drin sind. Also wir haben das Leistungsschutzrecht im Koalitionsvertrag,
Und auch wenn niemand sich öffentlich hinstellt von den Parlamentariern und sagt, das Leistungsschutzrecht ist eine super Idee,
Gibt's da diesen Druck, eben durch die Interessen, dadurch, dass das im Koalitionsvertrag steht und dass man sich im anstehenden Wahlkampf nicht mit Springer anlegen möchte,
ähm das noch durchzukriegen. Wir haben, die machen auch wirklich Druck. Schon Ende Januar sind die Anhörungen im Rechtsausschuss. Das könnte sein, theoretisch könnten die das im Februar schon verabschieden, wenn wir nicht irgendeinen,
Zensursula oder Acta-Moment hinbekommen in der öffentlichen Empörung,
den ich bisher aber leider noch nicht sehe, sogar Google hat's versucht, auf ihre fucking Startseite und es hat nicht gezündet.
Wird aber auch die Wirkung von dieser Google-Starte stark überschätzt.
Es ist doch die Startseite vom Internet, hat Linus vorhin gesagt, obwohl das ist jetzt Facebook, ne?
Der Anfang vom Internet.
Also.
Ja. Also Google ist da, wo man sich für Facebook einloggt.
Ich will keine Prognose abgeben, aber sieht derzeit echt, echt schwierig aus, wenn wir das noch kippen wollen. Stimmt ja aber zu, dass sobald das in Kraft ist
jede Menge Prozesse anfangen
äh vor Gerichten. Äh aber da wir auch noch nicht mal irgendwie den endgültigen Entwurf haben, geschweige denn das, wie es dann wirklich verabschiedet wird. Äh ist auch noch unklar zu sagen, wie denn das denn von Gerichten gesehen wird und
Was für eine? Wir haben nächstes Jahr Bundestagswahl, was für eine Regierung es danach gibt, ob wir so einen Glücksfall wie bei Zensur Solar bekommen, dass die neue Regierung ganz schnell das schlechte Gesetz der Alten noch kippen könnte,
das kommt halt drauf an wer dann auch in der Region.
Könnte auch beschließen, dass man das Ganze auf die nächste Legislaturperiode äh verschiebt. Das wollen die nicht, aber.
Wollen die nicht, weil dann haben sie, dann haben sie ihren, dann haben sie Springer im Nacken, weil sie ihren ähm Koalitionsbeschluss verraten und damit Springer verraten haben, das will niemand.
Wäre ja nicht der erste äh Koalitionsbeschluss, äh den sie verraten hätten. Ich meine, da war auch mal was mit Atomkraft und so. Ähm ja, ich glaube zwar jetzt nicht, dass wir im Bereich Leistungsschutzrichtung Fukushima im Moment äh
äh hinbekommen, aber äh weiß der Geier, wohin äh sich das alles noch äh steigert,
allein schon, weil es ja auch eine zunehmende Aufmerksamkeit gibt für die sonstigen
Teilnehmer des Internets, weil es ja jetzt, ich meine, früher mag das ja so gewesen sein, dass Springer das einzige war, weil die Zeitungen sind die Medienmacht und fertig,
Aber es ist ja halt jetzt auch so, dass äh auch ein Wahlkampf in zunehmenden Maße im Internet stattfindet. Ich will das nicht überhöhen, ja? Aber äh der Trend ist klar. Und es gibt auch andere Medien und die sehen das anders.
Die Frage ist halt, möchtest du eine Bundestagswahl? Möchtest du dich in deinen Bundestagswahlkampf auf die Seite von Google verlassen?
Nein, aber hat sich nicht hat sich nicht sogar auch jetzt bin ich ein bisschen durcheinander. Hat sich nicht der Bitcom oder der Arbeitgeberverband, was war denn das? Irgendjemand hat sich doch auch im Wesentlichen.
Also auch, sagen wir mal, aus absolut unverdächtig kreisen, ja, gibt's mittlerweile da sehr große Bedenken.
Das war der Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie und die hatten das der BDI und,
Die sind tatsächlich mächtig, die hatten das zu einem Zeitpunkt, als in dem Gesetz noch vermutet wurde, dass jeder Rechner
zu Geschäftszwecken benutzt wird, quasi in all den Firmen von BDI. Wenn der dazu genutzt wird, diese äh,
Presseverlage der entsprechenden Leistungsschutzrechtsgeschützten Verlegeraufrufen, dass diese dann zahlen müssten,
was mittlerweile im aktuellen Gesetzentwurf so glaube ich nicht drin ist aber das ist natürlich für die ein Schreckenszenario, weil die dann jede Menge Kohle.
Genau, also das ist aber der Punkt. Es zeichnet sich so viele potentielle Kollateralschäden ab, dass wenn,
andere Branchen und Gruppen darauf aufmerksam gemacht werden, dass da sehr wohl eine durchaus auch konservativ nahestehende äh Verbandsstruktur auf einmal mit dem Kopf schüttelt
nicht die Zeitungsverleger ist, weil am Ende sind die Zeitungsverleger auch nur eine Gruppe von mehreren.
Und sie sind auch nicht in zunehmend sie sind auch in zunehmenden Maße nicht mehr die Alleinherrscher über den politischen Diskurs. Was sie ja bisher.
Sie sind definitiv noch der größte Anteil, gar keine Frage, aber es ist nicht so, dass ihnen dieser Kuchen alleine gehört.
Ich denke trotzdem und gerade nachdem was andere äh zu dem Thema nochmal gesagt hat, ich glaube Leistungsschutz reviert beschlossen,
Und Google wird dann kein Interesse mehr haben, das auch noch mit irgendwelchen
Gerichtsverfahren auszudefinieren, wie es dann am Ende aussehen soll, weil was sie immer nicht haben wollen, sind Gerichtsurteile und Gesetze. So, ich meine, das will Google einfach nicht. Und ich glaube, wenn das Leistungsschutzrecht beschlossen wird, wird Google sagen, alles klar
hier Christoph Käse oder wer auch immer dann da der der Chefunterhändler ist um um da die Preise auszuhandeln, dann wird Google sagen, komm mal her,
Äh guck mal, hier ist unsere Portokasse. Äh wie viel möchtest du daraus haben?
Damit wir uns einig sind, weil was Google nicht möchte, ist irgendein wenn wenn dann eben dieses schwammige,
Unausgegorene Leistungsschutzrichter ist, glaube ich nicht, dass Google das noch von irgendwelchen äh Gerichten irgendwie äh da ausdefiniert haben möchte, wenn sie Pech haben, irgendwie an so ein
debieren Richter geraten, der dann da auf einmal irgendein Vollquatsch reininterpretiert. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das Risiko haben wollen, dann werden sie eher sagen
was weiß ich so die den belgischen Weg,
gehen oder so, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie Bock haben bei einem über die Auslegung und Interpretation eines bestehenden Gesetzes noch äh Gerichtsverfahren zu führen,
Das ist das, was wo ich mich ich bin ja der einzige am Tisch, der sich, der sich mal festlegt.
Naja gut, wir werden's sehen. Was hatten wir denn noch Schönes? Ganz viele Petitionen hatten wir.
Petitionsmarkt, der ist auch übersättigt, finde ich.
Der Petitionsmarkt.
Pettition.
Echt, der der Peti, wir könnten mal eine Petition gegen Petitionen machen.
Genau. Eine Petition, dass wir weniger.
Wir wollen keinen, die wollen das nicht mehr.
Gab's nicht auf eine Petition, dass die Petition endlich mal ernst nehmen soll?
Das wäre die andere Variante, ne? Aber es ist so ein bisschen so zum Puppens äh äh geworden so, ah, wenn man jetzt hier eine Initiative macht und man hat nicht mal zumindest eine Petition gestartet und dann hat man,
diese magischen fünfzigtausend und so. Ich glaube, das nützt sich dann doch sehr äh ab,
Das hat man auch schon gemerkt, gerade bei der äh Petition ging's Leistungsschutzrecht, die ja so ein bisschen,
untergegangen ist, andere waren zwar erfolgreicher, aber am Ende sind das,
ist es eigentlich ein sehr zahnloser Tiger. Man lebt da, glaube ich, auch noch so ein bisschen in dieser äh romantisierenden äh Erinnerung
weißt du noch, damals für alle für die Petition waren und so weiter. Da war das halt ein großes Ereignis, aber irgendwie
war's das dann glaube ich auch erstmal so. Also man
kann an der Stelle jetzt, glaube ich, äh äh gut dazu übergehen, sich mal was Neues einfallen zu lassen, äh diese,
Aktivismus,
Netzgestützter Aktivismus muss sich auch neue Wege suchen, denke ich, ja? Und auch jenseits von solchen Bekloppten äh äh vom Bundestag schlecht betriebenen Webseiten. Ähm da muss einfach ähm,
Die Vernetzung als solche einfach besser organisiert werden.
Es gibt euch noch ein ein interessanten Aspekt dieser Petition, der äh häufig äh vielleicht gar nicht so auffällt,
Wann diese Petition freigeschaltet wird und plötzlich im Internet ist, unterliegt nicht der Kontrolle des Petenten,
unterliegt niemandes Kontrolle. Äh das heißt, deine Petition kann gut getimet sein oder schlecht getimt sein und muss dann,
die Aufmerksamkeit generieren, wenn sie randommäßig plötzlich vom Himmel fällt und freigeschaltet wird. Das heißt, kampagnenmäßig hast du einen Nachteil
solchen Petitionen, weil du nicht genau weißt, wann die äh zündet, solang, so lange du die Petitionsplattform, äh Epe Petition oder was da nutzt, ja? Die uns der Bundestag, Edition Punkt Bundestag DE
uns da zur Verfügung stellt. Das heißt also so im Rahmen einer Kampagne kann dir das halt hast du nicht die Kontrolle über deine Petition,
Haben sie so den Nachteil gegenüber so Plattformen wie wie heißen die Avas, wo dann die Acta äh Petition war, die dann natürlich einfach ihre eigene Petition da machen,
mit ihrer auf ihrer eigenen Infrastruktur, die dann aber natürlich wiederum keine Relevanz hat für den Petitionsausschuss. Also mit den Petitionen ist irgendwie.
Aber was was hat mir die Petition gegen ist ja dann quasi jetzt relativ leise, das äh war dann äh war jetzt dann zu Ende, weil der wurde ja entsprochen, es gibt keine Netzsperren. Das heißt, das.
Petition gegen Netzsperren war schon.
Du kannst Petition eh nicht entsprechen, alles was dir die Petition einräumt ist das Recht zu reden. Und dann darfst du da sagen ja aber und dann sagen sie alle ja schön dass sie da gewesen sind äh wir müssen jetzt weitermachen. Danke.
Ja aber und die sagen ja danke.
Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, dass Sie zu uns gesprochen haben.
Genau, ich war ja dieses Jahr bei der Anhörung der Petition zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung zur Abschaffung, die hat's ja auch geschafft, äh das Quorum zu erreichen. Dann gab's eine Anhörung im Petitionsausschuss. Und dann gab's ja diese.
Petition zum Leistungsschutzrecht, die glaube ich ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit in unserer Filter-Bubble bekommen hat,
Ähm habe dann danach auf Netzpolitik geschrieben, dass der Petitionsausschuss im Bundestag so ungefähr der unwichtigste Ausschuss ist, den es da,
auch wenn das nicht alle so sehen, vor allem die Abgeordneten, die da drin sitzen,
ähm aber dass das,
dass eine Petition die Juro der Jura sowieso nicht unmittelbar dazu führt, dass der Wille der Petition dann auch ernst genommen wird vom Parlament,
und dann umgesetzt wird, das ist allen klar und deswegen ist meine Einschätzung eher, dass man mit so einer Petition eben wie es zu Sensor geglückt ist, dieses eine Tool nimmt,
um damit Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren und eben öffentliche Wahrnehmung in den Medien zu landen, seinen Standpunkt öffentlich klar zu machen und dann dadurch durch die schiere Masse von Leuten, die da unterschreiben, Aufmerksamkeit auf das Thema zu lenken,
aber natürlich,
das nicht, dass man automatisch alle Abgeordneten von seiner Position überzeugt, denn die hatten ja auch vorher schon viele davon äh Positionen zu diesem Thema und wie immer geht's halt auch,
um Interessen und man wird einen.
CSU-Abgeordneten schlecht von einer Petition gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung überzeugen, äh wo er dann denkt, ja stimmt, wenn jetzt fünfzigtausend Leute dagegen sind, dann überlege ich mir das nochmal.
Wir sollten.
Wir haben das genutzt und sollten das äh eventuell weiter nutzen, um eine um die Aufmerksamkeit für unser Thema zu erregen, aber vielleicht bekommen die wir ja auch äh ganz anders diese Aufmerksamkeit als über dieses eine Tool.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, wie Gruppen, wie zum Beispiel Camp-Act, das Netz nutzen, ja, um dort äh die Leute zu mobilisieren,
Das denke ich zeigt.
Für mich sehr viel mehr in welche Richtung es gehen muss. Also die tatsächliche Mobilisierung im Sinne von Überzeugungsarbeit leisten braucht einfach noch sehr viel mehr Leute die eben
aktiver werden, als jetzt nur mit, na ja, ich klicke jetzt hier mal, ich bin dafür an und fertig und so, ne, ist dieser Klickivismus, der.
Hat halt jetzt mal funktioniert und funktioniert vielleicht auch noch ein zweites und drittes Mal. Aber das
kann jetzt keine Basis sein für nachhaltige politische äh Veränderungen und
es gibt die Piraten, die haben da äh ihren Weg gewählt, da werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal ähm drüber reden. Aber ich denke, für ähm die Kategorie engagierter Bürger, der eine konkrete Meinung hat, muss im Prinzip der Zugang,
zu den Abgeordneten, zu den tatsächlichen Entscheidungsträgern da kürzer werden. Und da können da muss, glaube ich, einerseits,
Generelle Mobilisierung nochmal stattfinden auch in den äh Köpfen, dass man diesen Schritt auch geht, ja. Bin da jetzt.
Genauso schuldig, ja? Ich meine, kann mich nicht erinnern, wann ich mal meinen Abgeordneten,
äh angerufen hätte wegen irgendetwas, ja, obwohl ich irgendwie weiß, das ist tatsächlich wahrscheinlich etwas, was sehr viel mehr bewirkt,
anruft und sagt, ja guten Tag, ich bin hier Bürger und so, ihr Wahlkreis, ja? Ich zahle ihre Rente hier quasi über Umwege,
und übrigens ich bin da nicht einverstanden. So und zwar weil und warum man das nicht macht hat natürlich auch was damit zu tun, dass man eben,
häufig die Argumentation so für sich selbst auch gar nicht so ohne weiteres
Nachvollzieht haben. Man ist irgendwie gefühlt irgendwie so ein bisschen dagegen, hat aber wahrscheinlich Angst vor der ersten Nachfrage
einen äh komplett aus der Spur wirft so, so nach dem Motto, ja ja wieso, das ist ja gar nicht so, ja, äh hm, dann stehst du da erstmal und stellst fest, dass du das Memo nicht gelesen hast.
Und äh das hält eben viele davon ab. Und ich denke, das sind auch so die Punkte, an denen man wahrscheinlich den äh Aktivismus ähm verbessern muss, dass man
nivellierter äh so ein so ein Micro-Titing äh äh auch auch macht. Nicht immer nur so. Hier ist unser zwölfseitiges Pamphlet. Wir sind dagegen
unterstütze uns jetzt, ja? Kauf irgendwie alles auf einmal, sondern dass man
vielleicht sehr viel mehr versucht, so 'ne so 'n bisschen ins Blaue hineingedacht und gesagt für mir, ja, also, dass man einfach versucht, das Ganze eben mehr zu atomisieren, dass man
hergehen, sagt, okay, was sind die Argumente in diesem ganzen Kontext, die verstanden werden müssen.
Was sind die einzelnen Aspekte, ähm die äh wirklich sitzen bleiben müssen. Und ich konzentriere mich darauf,
auch mal das kleinen Sachen erstmal sich manifestieren zu lassen. Auf welchem Wege auch immer, um einfach auch ein besseres
und damit eben auch eine bessere Argumentationsfähigkeit zu schaffen. Man man muss sich quasi die Mitdiskutanten und Mitargumentierer die emotional ohnehin schon,
der eigenen Seite sind, mehr auch in die Lage versetzen, eine ähm
Debatte zu führen und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das bei manchen dann auch dazu führt, dass sie eben genau in der Lage sind, diesen Schritt dann auch zu gehen und zu sagen, ich gehe mal auf diese öffentliche Veranstaltung, äh wo der Politiker sitzt oder ich rufe den an oder ich diskutiere jetzt mal auf eine halbe Stunde am
Wahlstand.
Ich sehe grade auf Andres Bildschirm, dass der schon dazu googelt, weil genau das wir wurde schon oft versucht,
Also lag vor der Tür hat er, glaube ich, häufiger die Aufrufe gemacht. Call your, äh Member of the European Parlament. Ähm da gab's sogar ein Tool, was
wirklich dann die Leute da, also ähnlich äh wie bei äh
bei Abgeordneten watchen, die nicht oder bei äh adoptier einen Abgeordneten oder bei der PNR-Kampagne, genau, die PNR-Kampagne von digitale Gesellschaft macht das, ne, mit Kontaktmöglichkeit, Kontaktiere, Heidrun
so und so jetzt und sage ihr äh warum sie dagegen stimmen soll. Ähm diese diese Kampagnen gibt es
und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass sie äh bis jetzt besonders starke Resonanz hatten, Andre, was äh,
meinst du zu solchen Sachen? Also man kann das natürlich auch immer nicht sehen, aber es scheint nicht so zu sein, als würden da hunderte ans ans Telefon greifen.
Hast du schon mal angerufen?
Ich habe äh teilweise die Listen geschrieben, bei wem anzurufen ist, das muss ja wohl reichen.
Siehst du? Ich so, Tim auch nicht. Ich,
Glück, jawohl, du wohnst im selben Wahlkreis wie ich, ich treffe meinen Bundestagsabgeordneten öfters mal auf Demos, nämlich den Herrn Ströbler und oft muss ich mit ihm gar nicht so viel diskutieren, auch wenn er das mit dem Internet nicht immer voll umfänglich versteht, ist er doch oft auf unserer Seite,
Das ist äh recht Luxus für uns, aber tatsächlich ist zum Abgeordneten gehen, das ist auch nur ein Mensch, der hat ein Bürgerbüro, der will für die Leute da sein, auftauchen,
argumentativ gewappnet sein und dann ähm ihm oder ihr einmal erzählen, warum das wirklich gerade überhaupt gar nicht geht, was da vorgeschlagen wird,
ähm.
Das hilft wahrscheinlich mehr als eine Petition, weil man sich damit unmittelbar auseinandersetzen muss. Und auch nicht alle Abgeordneten sind Experten in jedem Thema,
kann ja vorher auch mal kurz googeln, ist der jetzt der äh Experte? Hat er eine Position, mit welcher Argumente bringt der,
da haben sie ja auch angerufen, äh ruft das Europaparlament an, die hatten auch dann so kleine Aduliner, so ungefähr wie,
fängst mit diesem Argument an und dann ist er entweder dafür oder dagegen und dann könntest du ungefähr das bringen und wenn er eins der Gegenargumente bekommt, kannst du diese so und so einfach äh kurz kontern,
Ist möglich, kostet ein bisschen Zeit, aber ich glaube, das bringt tatsächlich unterm Strich mehr als die nächste Petition. Äh ob nun bei Kampak oder äh,
Bundestag DE.
Wurde das genannt.
Das ist so ein Wort, was ich grade genannt habe, weiß das, glaube ich, im Englischen gibt.
Ist das? Ist das so ein, also ist das nur so eine Textsammlung sozusagen, so ein so ein so ein Struktogramm, so ein so ein so ein Fließdiag.
Gesprächsleitfaden.
So kann das zum Beispiel aussehen.
Wäre das ja, wenn man das so als ähm.
Elisaartig, dass man sich sozusagen ich ich also ja und dann geht man da rein und äh äh geht das so interaktiv durch. Also das ist das, was ich meine. Also vielleicht auch spielerisch.
Könnten wir da nicht auch so machen so? Hallo, ich wohne in ihrem Abgeordneten, in ihrem Wahlkreis. Sind sie gegen Akta? Drücken sie eins für ja, zweifeln nein.
Ich sehe schon, wo man mit Argumentationen irgendwie äh zu Explosionen herbeiführen muss,
Ja, der Kreativität sind ja äh Gott sei Dank keine Grenze gesetzt, von daher könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man da noch auf das eine oder andere kommt. Und wahrscheinlich ist die,
Das, was wirklich funktioniert, wird eine ganz einfache Lösung, die aber so noch nicht gefunden ist. Also das sind alles ganz interessante äh Sachen. Woran es natürlich auch sehr hängt, ist.
Politik muss halt sexy werden. Es heilt,
Also ist schon sehr viel also auf dieser Actad Demo der sagenumwobenen, wo ich ja, weißt du noch, waren wir da nicht zusammen? Ne, ne, wir waren, aber wir waren beide da, ne? Wir waren da nicht zusammen. Hier in Berlin, meine ich.
Ja ja ich ich weiß, ich war hier in Berlin. Ja, ja, du meinst du die Große oder die Kleine? Weil.
Es gab im Januar, da war es.
Große. Ja, ja, die.
Und dem Juni da, die war eher klein.
Genau, es gab im Januar eine große.
Die große meine ich. Da wo die wo so viele junge Leute da waren, die wir nicht kannten,
So und wo wir alle etwas überrascht waren. So, ja? Da war das auf einmal irgendwie cool.
So, ja? Und äh das hat zwar jetzt nicht ewig gehalten, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach genau das Ding, ja. Das muss halt irgendwie cool sein,
Und nicht nur, weil es, wie das Richtige ist oder so, sondern,
Sage jetzt auch nicht, dass man jetzt äh mit Dieter Bohlen dafür werben sollte oder so, sondern das muss einfach gelingen äh äh das zu verbinden
dass einfach gesellschaftliches Argument auch ähm ausreichend ähm attraktiv ist, dass man sich daran beteiligen möchte, dass man auch sieht, es bewirkt etwas, et cetera PP.
Das war diese Februar-Demo angemeldet, glaube ich, mit fünfhundert Personen. Am Ende waren irgendwie fünf bis zehntausend da.
Und hat uns dann dazu bewogen, im Juni meintest du, bei der zweiten, bei der warmen Actademo ein siebeneinhalb Tonner zu mieten und eine Anlage draufzuschnallen, was so ungefähr der,
Beste ist, was du an PA Equipment auf siebeneinhalb Tonner schnallen kannst. Ähm und dann sind wir mit,
guten achthundert Leuten äh durch Berlin gegangen mit dieser Anlage, die äh entlang des Weges alle Autoalarmanlagen ausgelöst hat, weil sie,
weiß ich ganz gut Bass hatte, ja? Aber da war kein Schwein mehr da.
Noch nicht mal getanzt, ey, das war wirklich ein bisschen dramatisch.
Ja, na ja, so ist es halt, ne?
Das war, das fand ich sexy. Na ja.
Wir stellen fest, es ist noch einiges äh zu leisten in diesem Bereich. Was hatten wir denn noch Schönes.
Ja, Andre ist dein Thema.
Ich dachte, du machst mir eine Einleitung.
Mach dir eine Einleitung. Ähm Funkzellenabfrage.
Das war, glaube ich, mein erster Look Netzpolitik dieses Jahr im Januar, was ich bei euch mal war und zwar ähm.
Haben wir mit Netzpolitik ORG das Thema Funkzellenabfrage,
so auf die Agenda der Berliner Politik gesetzt. Wir hatten ja da diese Akte von diesem einen Fall, wo wir exemplarisch gezeigt haben, hier wird ein Auto angezündet, irgendwie ein paar hundert oder paar tausend Euro Schaden.
Und was gemacht wird, ist, es werden eintausende,
Kommunikationszeiten von Mobiltelefonen, von der Polizei eingesammelt und geraspelt mit anderen äh solchen Fällen abgeglichen,
haben damit so einen kleinen Stein ins Rollen gebracht, äh dass die Berichterstattung,
immer weiter ging und dann die Polizei erstmals also nachdem die uns wochenlang überhaupt gar nicht geantwortet haben,
aber als dann auch die Abgeordneten und die Berliner Opposition Druck gemacht haben und auch der Datenschutzbeauftragte ein bisschen überrascht und schockiert war,
mussten die dann wirklich mal Zahlen auf den Tisch legen, die im Laufe des Jahres immer weiter gestiegen sind,
Immer noch keine abschließenden Zahlen, aber mindestens zu nur zu Autobrandstiftungen in Berlin wurden in den letzten drei Jahren achthundert Funkzellenabfragen gemacht,
seit seit dem gab's mehr als eintausendvierhundert Funkzellenabfragen in Berlin,
wo insgesamt hochgerechnet mehr als dreißig Millionen Verbindungsdaten abgefragt wurde. Das ist so statistisch gesehen jeder Berliner alle sechs Monate ist einmal in so einem Ding drin.
Ähm dass das Auto Ausmaß, Auto, dass das Ausmaß tatsächlich so groß ist.
War glaube ich den wenigsten bekannt, ist jetzt endlich mal in der Öffentlichkeit, auch wenn da irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr Empörung gehen könnte, äh für,
meiner Meinung nach vorher war das so abstrakt und so die paar Experten,
wussten, dass es da irgend so ein Paragraphen hundert G gibt, ähm wussten, dass man sowas machen kann. Man hat dann in Dresden äh letztes Jahr,
Anti-Nazi-Aktionen um den dreizehnten Februar herum mit voller Empörung festgestellt, dass sowas mal gemacht wurde,
und hat gedacht, ja, Einzelfall nur in Sachsen und wir haben das halt jetzt für Berlin tatsächlich in über tausend Fällen,
dokumentiert, auch wenn's äh das noch ein bisschen offizieller und detaillierter sein könnte. Aber das ist auch, was wir bisher haben.
Einfall in Dresden und ein bisschen was in Berlin, was auch noch nicht alles von den Fällen ist, die es in Berlin gab,
das passiert auch an den anderen Bundesländern, da haben wir leider noch nichts, wir versuchen jetzt Zahlen zu bekommen, um das auch da mal auf die Tagesordnung äh zu hieven.
Ähm haben noch nicht wirklich viele, weil's ja auch noch nicht so wirklich Statistiken gibt und so weiter und so äh Fortdetails. Worauf ich noch hinweisen möchte,
der Bericht, den dann der Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragte Dix erstellt hat, der hat sich mal äh hundert solcher Akten äh Ermittlungsakten angeguckt,
und mit der Polizei gesprochen.
Wie denn diese funktionellen Abfragen durchgeführt werden, was denn da so passiert und ob da alles nach Recht und Gesetz gibt. Da kann ich nur empfehlen, den Bericht,
kommt zu einem niederschmetternden Urteil und zwar haben die Behördenermittlungen Behörden auch äh staatsanwaltschaften, Polizei so ziemlich jeden Fehler gemacht,
den sie hätten machen können und auch Gesetze gebrochen. Also die haben mehrmals Funkzellenabfragen gemacht,
Straftat gab einmal Gutachter danach rausgekommen, das Auto hat gar niemand angezündet, das war die Heizung, die einen Kurzschluss hatte,
Ähm die ha, die haben Funktionen auf Fragen durchgeführt,
von Zeiträumen über acht Stunden, von massig Funkzellen, danach haben sie die Daten nie benutzt, sollen haben sie nie verwendet,
sollen aber dann trotzdem dreißig Jahre gespeichert werden oder die haben erstmal 'ne Funktion gemacht und dann den Zeugen von Tatort gefragt und das geht alles nicht laut den,
Gesetzesbestimmung, der Bericht ist sehr erhellend, hat aber leider noch nicht wirklich zu Konsequenzen geführt, äh weder in der Berliner Politik,
noch in der bundesweiten Politik. Also wir können annehmen, dass dieses Mittel auch weiterhin eingesetzt wird,
wenn vielleicht auch nicht mehr ganz so schnell äh wie vor der öffentlichen Empörung. Äh aber das ist weiterhin und das war Zitat von Ermittlungsbehandeln. Ja äh Standard äh Ermittlungsmaßnahme.
Du hattest glaube ich noch so einen Artikel geschrieben äh bei NSU-Ermittlungen, nationalsozialistischer Untergrund, zwanzig Millionen Verbindungsdaten, vierzehntausend Namen und Adressen, Nulltäter, stand da glaube ich im Titel?
Genau, zu den ähm Morden und Anschlägen der des NSU wurden natürlich auch Funkellenabfragen von den einzelnen Behörden durchgeführt,
und die haben, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, äh die haben auch zwanzig Millionen äh Verbindungsdatensätze. Und zwar wird die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
mit Terrorismus begründet, damals haben sie noch nicht mal gedacht, dass das Terrorismus ist und das heißt immer nur, wenn wir einen Verdächtigen haben, wollen wir dessen Kommunikationswissen äh Netzwerk, wollen wir wissen, wen er angerufen hatte, von wem er angerufen wurde? Es passiert genau andersrum. Man hat einen riesen Satz, nimmt einmal alles, was da ist
und rastet das dann. Die haben zwanzig Millionen Datensätze, die haben von vierzehntausend Mobilfunkanschlussinhabern,
Name und Adresse äh eingeholt. Von vierzehntausend Telefonnummern,
Auf wen ist die registriert? Und haben natürlich die Ermittlungserfolg bei den ganzen Ermordungen äh bei den ganzen Ermittlungen zur NSU-Terrorserie ist ja bekannt. Die haben niemals irgendjemand gefunden und.
Beate Zschäpe haben sie erwischt.
Ja genau wie den Dreiweg mit äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Nee, ähm die Daten,
haben die mehr eingesammelt, als wir uns das jemals hätten vorstellen können, als wir gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung waren. Und haben trotzdem niemand erwischt. Auch bei Autobrandstiftungen in Berlin haben die nicht eine einzige Person,
damit ermittelt. Die haben wir überhaupt nur zwei, drei Mal einen Räuber bekommen oder so,
beziehungsweise einmal vielleicht sogar noch 'ne Vergewaltigung oder so aber von tausenden Fällen ist das schon ganz schön mau.
Aber geändert hat sich jetzt nichts an der an der Lage. Es wird nach wie vor.
Rechtlich geändert hat sich nicht weder in Berlin äh noch im Bund äh die äh äh Paragraphen sind genau wie vorher,
de facto könnte es sein, dass eben durch den öffentlichen Druck,
kleinen öffentlichen Druck durch so einen Bericht vom Datenschutzbeauftragen, der sich empört gezeigt hat, Druck der Opposition
eventuell vielleicht jetzt äh auch Ermittlungsrichter oder Staatsanwälte sich wirklich mal genauer überlegen, wie sind denn jetzt wirklich alle rechtlichen Bestimmungen eingehalten und nicht wieder so ein peinlicher Bericht von Herrn Dicks veröffentlicht wird, dass wirklich jeder Fehler gemacht wird, der gemacht werden kann,
aber die Funkzellen Nachfrage passiert weiterhin und ich finde, das ist ein prima Beispiel, wie die Daten, die auch ähm bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesammelt werden, wirklich genutzt werden.
Eben nicht um eine Einzelperson, was hat der gemacht, sondern gebt uns mal alles und wir rastern das.
Ganz kurz noch, bei den Autorentzündungen haben sie aber doch am Ende irgendjemanden äh irgendjemand würde doch dann da festgenommen, oder? Der Auto ist angezeigt, dass man.
Ein Typ, der immer mit einem BVG-Bus hingefahren ist und dann hatten sie äh die Videoüberwachung von den ganzen Tatorten, von dem äh,
Von den U-Bahn Haltestellen und BVG Bussen.
Das war ein, glaube ich, arbeitsloser, frustrierter Mensch, ja.
Danach haben sie mit Funkzellen das war ja genau und danach haben sie mit den FZA äh Daten festgestellt, ach ja stimmt, der war ja überall.
Und das war kein ähm kein Terrorist. Das war ein ja, ein arbeitsloser sich äh benachteiligt fühlender.
Mich benachteiligt fühlender. Ich glaube, der hatte jetzt keine politische Motivation außer Frustration, ja.
Gut, ähm was hatten wir noch? Informationsfreiheits äh Gesetz äh.
Ja, wir hatten doch äh äh das Gespräch hatten wir mit Stefan Wehrmeyer bei unserer äh Sendung, die ungefähr ein Jahr alt ist, beziehungsweise einundfünfzig Wochen.
Fragt den Staat.
Den Staat DE.
Auf dem letzten Kongress aufgenommen.
Auf dem letzten Kongress aufgenommen. Man konnte es mit dieser Plattform sehr einfach äh Anfragen nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz äh stellen und das äh wurde ja in einigen
Fällen die zu einiger Prominenz gelangen auch gemacht. Zum Beispiel erinnern wir uns an ähm
Anfrage stellte wer denn acta wer da die Unterhändler für Akter sind und die Antwort bekam, dass man ihm das irgendwie nicht sagen würde. Wir erinnern uns an,
Die IFG Anfrage zum Thema Leistungsschutzrecht, die der Andre gestellt hat.
Jetzt gerade die aktuelle?
Ja, das war letzte Woche und zwar der Sascha Lobo äh rausgefunden, dass im Staatsminister im Bundeskanzleramt der Bruder vom Axel Springer,
Lobbyist, die Gebrüder von Kleiden und wir wollten mal wissen,
was gibt's überhaupt für Dokumente zum Leistungsschutzrecht im Bundeskanzleramt? Weil das ja irgendwie Chefsache ist und vor allem, welche Rolle spielt der Eckart von Kleiden in diesem gesamten Prozess?
Ja, unsere äh Anfrage wurde abgelehnt, denn die Beantwortung dieser Anfrage könnte den Erfolg der Entscheidung vereiteln.
Geil, oder?
Das mag vom Markt.
Sage ich mal, äh äh ist das ist das eine Checkbox? Ist das eine vorgesehene Checkbox bei der Absage oder ist das, also ich meine, damit kommen die doch nicht durch, oder?
Sie könnten uns ja auf die Schliche kommen. Das fällt ihnen allen nachzufragen.
Sorry, so das das scheint zu, da könnte hier irgendwie das könnte politische Konsequenzen haben, wenn wir ihnen das sagen.
Also tatsächlich ähm gelten IFG-Anfragen nicht für laufende Prozesse, die noch nicht abgeschlossen sind
und da ist eben äh der Hintergrund also hier unten gibt's ein äh Absatz
Vertraulichkeit, behördlicher Beratungen und so, zudem sind Bundeskanzleramtsachen eh immer alles Verschlusssache, die Protokolle und äh solange der Vorgang noch läuft, kann man auch keinen Einblick bekommen. Das steht tatsächlich im Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, aber
Tatsächlich ist diese äh Ablehnung einer,
Offenlegung könnte den Erfolg der Entscheidung vereiteln, äh ein Zitat aus diesem äh Antwortbrief, den wir vom Bundeskanzleramt erhalten haben,
steht doch sehr symptomatisch dafür, dass man nicht möchte,
ein bisschen mehr Transparenz reinzubringen, was ja bestimmt möglich wäre, wenn man, wenn man das denn wollte.
Könnt ihr den Erfolg der Entscheidung.
Erfolg der Entscheidung. Eine Entscheidung kann nur Erfolg haben, weil sie wird immer getroffen. Die Frage ist, wie viel sie getroffen? Oder, also ich meine, der.
Na, aber kein Leistungsschutzrecht ist kein Erfolg.
Aber auch eine Entscheidung. Seine erfolgte Entscheidung.
Na ja, was hatten wir noch? Äh die äh die Bürgerschaftsinitiative Transparenz schafft Vertrauen. Also wir hatten durchaus einiges, was so Informationsfreiheit angeht, ne. Ähm,
Dann hatten wir das die die Einladungsliste zu Ackermanns Geburtstagsparty im Kanzleramt. Die hattet ihr ja auch irgendwie über ähm,
Das IFG über eine IFG-Anfrage bekommen.
Genau, der über diese Geburtstagsparty von Deutsch Bankchef Ackermann im wieder Bundeskanzleramt fällt mir gerade auf, die andere Journalisten schon erklagt hatten,
nach IFG äh und nach Gerichtsurteilen dann das Kanzleramt dazu gezwungen würde, die nach Informationsfreiheitsgesetz rauszugeben. Und wo dann auch angefragt haben, ja wollen wir haben, aber mit dieser Liste äh dann dazu äh,
bekommen haben. Den Hinweis, ihr könnt jetzt zwar haben, weil wir das nach EFG rausgeben müssen, aber ihr dürft das nicht veröffentlichen, weil das ist unser Urheberrecht.
Und nee, beziehungsweise Urheberrecht war gar nicht bei Ackermann, sondern bei der nächsten beim.
Genau. Äh trotzdem, weil man nicht möchte, dass man das veröffentlicht und uns diesen äh Erlaubnissen nicht gibt,
Sollten wir das nicht tun, haben wir nicht eingesehen, weil das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist für die Informationsfreiheit und wenn wir das nur lesen äh und nicht teilen könnten, dann,
sehen wir da nicht wirklich Informationsfreiheit gewährleistet, haben das dann doch auf den Netzpolitikserver gepackt, veröffentlicht.
Nochmal ein bisschen runde gemacht, aber das Kanzleramt hat dann irgendwann ähm aufgegeben und deswegen verklagen zu wollen.
Wobei das beim Korruptionsgutachten noch nicht ganz so ist. Also da haben wir auch angefragt, äh fragt die Stadt, die ist sehr schöne Plattform. Ich muss aber einen kleinen Disclaimer anfügen. Ich habe da den das System und den Mailsäure aufgesetzt. Wie auch immer. Ähm,
Wir haben auch eine IFG-Anfrage nach einem Gutachten der wissenschaftlichen Dienste zum,
zur Abgeordneten Korruption,
angefragt, dass auch schon, ach, ich glaube, das war von zwotausendsieben oder so, ich hab den Artikel jetzt grade nicht vor mir, jedenfalls ist das alt,
Wir wollten das äh haben, das gab's auch per Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, aber wieder mit dem Hinweis, ihr dürft jetzt zwar haben, weil wir's rausgeben müssen
aber ihr dürft das nicht veröffentlichen, diesmal aber wirklich mit dem Grund, weil das unterliegt dem Urheberrecht der wissenschaftlichen Dienste des Deutschen Bundestages und wir äh
erlauben eine Veröffentlichung nicht. Haben wir wieder nicht eingesehen?
Da ist es wieder.
Tatsächlich jetzt als politisches Instrument. Haben wir wieder nicht eingesehen, haben es wieder auf den Server gepackt, veröffentlicht, ging auch ein bisschen rum,
Irgendwann kam ein Brief vom vom Wissenschaftlichen Dienst. Die haben gemeint, ey wir haben, wir haben das ernst gemeint mit dem nicht veröffentlichen. Also bitte nehmt das runter, sonst.
Und das ist glaube ich der letzte Stand. Äh seitdem ist nichts weiter passiert. Wir hoffen, dass der dann eingetretene Barbara Streisen Effekt ähm dazu geführt hat, dass sie's auch nicht mehr versuchen werden,
Sicher können wir uns nicht zu einem tatsächlich ist das juristisch noch nicht ganz ausbaldowert, ob Zone Antwort hier nach IFG müssen, wie die das geben, aber du darfst, aber du erzähl niemandem, was drin steht, ob das tatsächlich rechtmäßig ist,
ist noch nicht abschließend gerichtlich geklärt. Wir sehen das nicht so, das ist überhaupt nicht den Geist des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes eine Antwort widerwillig zu geben, die aber nicht veröffentlichen zu dürfen.
Und genau dahin gehen ja auch die politischen Forderungen,
Informationsfreiheit von einem äh Pool auf das Push-Prinzip umgesetzt äh umgestellt werden sollte, dass man nicht als Bürger anfragen muss, bitte gebt mir doch mal,
dieses zum Thema X, von dem du schon genau weißt, dass es existiert, sondern andersrum. Äh wir bezahlen.
Äh wir bezahlen.
Staat mit unseren Steuern und deswegen sind die Informationen, die dort produziert, werden,
gehören die natürlich auch uns in den USA ist das viel einfacher, da ist das Public Domain und öffentlich und fertig.
In Deutschland ist das noch nicht ganz so weit, auch wenn der Bundesbeauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit das fordert, das Hamburger Gesetz, Transparenz schafft Vertrauen, äh,
Das glaube ich sogar für Hamburg durchsetzt, oder? Oder zumindest weit in diese Richtung,
auf Bundesebene ähm ist da noch Druck notwendig, dass dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in diese Richtung auszuweiten.
Ist die Frage auch, was ja die Fold ist. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt irgendwie allem hinterher fragen und klagen muss, um äh das dann mal veröffentlicht zu bekommen, wo ein Anrecht darauf besteht und dann muss nochmal explizit festgestellt werden, ob denn das jetzt überhaupt,
sein darf oder nicht, könnte man ja den Spieß auch genauso umdrehen und sagen, alles, was nicht explizit
für eine Veröffentlichung ausgeschlossen ist, wird automatisch einfach öffentlich
Es taucht einfach auf nach irgendeiner Karenz äh Zeit, nicht? Wenn sich das äh so gut festlegen lässt, wann etwas abgeschlossen ist und wann nicht, dann kann man ja sehr wohl nach Abschluss äh das auch entsprechend ähm,
offen machen, ne. Na gut, ähm.
Sich noch, aber es bewegt sich. Also da sehe ich überhaupt eine ganze Menge Bewegung und äh das ist, glaube ich, auch ein gutes, gutes Beispiel für so ein Aktivismus-Tool, was einfach den Zugang zur Politik erheblich,
Einfacher gemacht hat an einer sehr wichtigen Stelle und davon brauchen wir noch mehr.
Es macht sogar richtig Spaß. Man drückt einfach Ministerium. Ich hätte gern die Dokumente, Klick, wartet eine Weile und wenn keine Antwort.
Kommt ein Fax.
Dann dann klickt man nochmal äh und schreibt eine Erinnerung, hier gesetzliche Frist überschritten und bitter äh und irgendwann kommt eine Mail oder ein Brief und da stehen dann tatsächlich Informationen drinne, oft
Manchmal muss man auch nochmal zum Telefonhörer greifen oder so und manche wollen die Information nicht veröffentlicht, aber kann ich nur empfehlen. Nutzt mehr, fragt den Staat.
Und.
Der politischen Beteiligung.
Was meinst du mit Craig-Level? Ich weiß immer nicht, was ein Craig-Level ist. Also ich kenne von früher Craig zocken.
Ja ja, halt sind doch diese ersten Games gewesen, wo man sich sozusagen auch seinen eigenen Level designen konnte,
Dieses ganze politische Plänefield,
ja, sich sozusagen so erschließbar zu machen, als würde man mit einem Avatar durch die Gegend des Kanzleramts zu äh laufen, ja.
Die ganzen bürokratischen Hürden da einfach besser nehmen kann, indem man einfach das entsprechende Tool hat, dass man da einfach geradezu dreidimensional durch den juristischen Apparat durchnavigiert, das muss das Ziel sein.
Tim, du willst mit einem Killerspiel die bürokratischen Hürden in der Kanzler.
Ich habe auch gerade gesagt, gedacht, wenige Tage nach einem wenige Tage nach medialen Ereignissen schlägt Tim vor, das Kanzleramt als Craig-Level nachzubauen.
Ja, aber ich will nicht, ich will ja nicht die Politiker alle umbringen, sondern ich will die.
Dokumente einsammeln.
Lehme, die einem normalerweise in dem im Weg stehen entsprechend ausräumen, ja?
Genauso wenig wie der Blut fließt, wirklich ist richtiges Blut, wird das auch hier nicht der Fall sein.
Okay, also Kanzleramt.
Browser sagen sollen, das zieht einfach nicht so gut, weißt du? Ich sage immer, braun, dann ein Politbrowser. Ja.
Level für die Politik. Aber es also Fazit, wir müssen, ey, wir haben ganz oft Fazit vergessen. Fazit, Informationsfreiheit, viel passiert in diesem Jahr, wird noch mehr passieren und gut.
Ein Wort möchte noch anmerken und zwar Open Data, die ganze in Deutschland doch recht äh aktive Open Data-Bewegung ist natürlich auch eng mit diesen Informationsfreiheits äh Gesetz verknüpft, aber auch anderen Initiativen. Und da gibt,
zarte Pflänzchen, die wirklich äh coole Sachen produzieren. Dies wird hoffentlich auch in den nächsten Jahren weiter zunehmen.
Welche zarten Pflänzchen?
Ne, die ganzen Open Data Initiativen und Projekte, OKFN äh frag den Staat, dann Vereine und auch diese Hamburger äh Gesetzesinitiative,
Berlin-Daten DE, Datenjournalismus, gibt's ja 'ne ganze Bandbreite von,
offenen Daten, Open Date da, Richtung Politik, Richtung Journalismus und überhaupt mehr Daten, mehr offen.
Mehr Daten mehr offen, mehr gut.
So, dann kommen wir noch zu den äh relativ jungen Ereignissen rund um die ITU, was eigentlich ja mehr so ein aktuelles Thema ist, aber auch so ein bisschen,
den Blick nach vorne einklagt wir erinnern uns die Konferenz der ITU fand jüngst statt.
Kurze Abkürzung IT, International Telegraph.
Telegraf war mal.
Telekomunikation, Telegraph, was sie jetzt hatten, war der WC IT, World Congress of International.
Information Technology.
Echt sogar.
Sagen wir einfach.
Weltgipfel der Technologie, Informationsgesellschaft.
Zentrum der Büro- und Informationstechnik. Das ist die Cebit.
Nee, das Ding ist WCIT oder wie man auch in Rapperkreise sagt.
Und dann wollten sie dort den ITA International Telekommunications Regulations machen.
ITAs, genau.
Genau. Und wen hatten wir am Start? MC Westerwelle?
Nee, die fahren doch damit nicht mit Ministerebene zu. Erst erstens, weil er Wirtschaftsministerium zuständig,
aber auch die haben keine hochrangigen Vertreter geschickt, sondern das war irgendwie auf Ebene von Abteilungsleiter.
So ungefähr,
Also das war jetzt nicht wie der Klimagipfel, wo äh auch der Minister oder gar die Kanzlerin äh selber hinfliegt, sondern das war,
Eher so ein Nürthema, aber wir hatten immerhin äh Wolfgang Kleinwächter, alter.
Internet Governance, Haudegen, äh in der deutschen Delegation dabei. Ich glaube, der Eco ist kurzfristig auch da. Auch dazu gekommen. Jimmy Schulz ist von sich aus hingefallen, Monika Ehrmann und Patrick Wolt haben glaube ich äh berichtet auch von vor Ort,
Also es gab äh,
Mehr medialer Öffentlichkeitsaufmerksamkeit auf so einen abstrakten internationalen Internet Governance Gipfel, vor allem äh IT-Gipfel äh als bisher.
Was natürlich auch an dem,
Aufreger vorher die ITU Bilders Internet kontrollieren, zensieren, China, Russland, Iran, die Achse des Bösen und das nationale Internet äh,
Ihr habt im Podcast, wie ihr auf Netzpolitik äh ja die ähm.
Panik verbreitet.
Naja, nee, die, die, die Claims abgesteckt, die da die einzelnen Akteure vorbringen wollten.
Wir haben bei der digitalen Gesellschaft eine Pressemitteilung geschrieben, dass der Gipfel so halb gescheitert ist. Ähm was passiert ist, ist,
vielen Diskussionen und obwohl bisher,
die IT-Gipfelentscheidungen meist im Konsens einstimmig gefallen sind, haben wir diesmal eine Kampfabstimmung gemacht,
über die neuen ITAs, die internationalen Telekommunikationsregulierungen.
Ähm wovon ungefähr zwei Drittel der Staaten, glaube ich, dafür gestimmt haben und das als Signal äh gilt, dass das international doch äh eine Mehrheit.
Aber.
Fast genau eine Mehrheit hat.
Die dort diskutierten äh neuen International Telekommunikation Regelations ITAs, gleich nochmal drauf, was ungefähr drin ist, aber ein Block,
aus äh westlichen Staaten, allen voran USA,
ähm aber auch andere europäische Staaten unter anderem Deutschland und ich glaube auch Ägypten und so äh haben sich gegen,
eine äh ja Unterschrift unter diesen neuen ITAs ausgesprochen,
war quasi so eine Art Spaltung äh im Ergebnis dieser Konferenz. Und zwar auch wenn die ITU ähm,
nach dem ganzen Shitstorm versucht hat, ihre ganzen Probleme anzugehen und versucht hat, Transparenz äh herzustellen. Die haben sogar,
die was war das? Von der ICAM,
eingeladen auf der Eröffnung äh mitzureden und so und ITU sind immer so zwei komplett,
Gegenspieler, die sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht leiden können, äh die haben versucht, Menschenrechte mit in den Vertrag aufzunehmen und überhaupt zu sagen, immer wieder, ich glaube jeden Tag, oder fast jede Stunde wurde auf diesem Panel in Dubai gesagt,
Nein, die ITU will das Internet nicht übernehmen. Ähm.
Tatsächlich ist äh der verabschiedete Vertrag dann so ein bisschen abgeschwächt und das sind nicht wirklich
die äh harten Vorschläge von,
komplette Renationalisierung drin, die vorher rumgeisterten. Trotzdem gibt es aus Augen der kritischen Staaten und auch Zivilgesellschaft einige kritische
die äh so ein bisschen acta-ähnlich schwammig formuliert sind und durchaus bedeuten könnten,
dass Staaten mehr Kontrolle über das Internet übernehmen und davor haben eben alle Angst und allen voran die USA, aber auch andere haben gesagt, nee, wenn da irgendwas in die Richtung drin steht, dann werden wir das nicht annehmen,
das haben die jetzt auch ähm zumindest für ihren Part,
Damit ist die Debatte aber glaube ich nicht vorbei, sondern diese ganze Frage um wer regiert das Internet.
Ähm ist auf internationaler national äh Ebene zwischen Nationalstaaten und Regierungschef,
glaube ich, durch diesen ganzen ITU-Prozess überhaupt erstmal auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt worden und äh auch dort,
viele verschiedene Interessen, äh die USA haben, das muss man auch ansprechen, natürlich ganz klar eigene Interessen und nicht nur die Freiheit äh des Internets im Blick, wenn sie die IT komplett ablehnen
und diese Debatten, wer hat wie viel Kontrolle über das Internet ähm,
wird auf internationaler politischer Ebene in den nächsten Jahren, glaube ich, weitergeführt werden.
Als Ergebnis von diesem IT-Gipfel.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass die Diskussion gerade erst eröffnet worden und da ist auch sicherlich äh,
Wichtig, dass da auch ähm das Netz da auch nochmal eine klare Stimme findet, weil so glücklich ist man ja erst mit der Ist-Situation auch nicht unbedingt,
und was wirklich so die Vision ist und vor allem, was auch so die Position der Stärke äh ist, aus der man solche Tendenzen letzten Endes äh verhindern, heraus verhindern, verhindern möchte. Ist mir auch noch nicht so ganz klar.
Ist ein wichtiger Punkt, weil also die Situation, ich meine, überleg mal, wir schaffen's mit Müh und Not,
uns auf nationaler Ebene irgendwie grob gegen gegen solche ähm,
zur Wehr zu setzen. Wir sehen eigentlich schon relativ blöd aus, wenn's um Europa geht, wenn's um die EU geht, ja, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland wurde zum Thema, da war es schon längst beschlossene Sache in der auf EU-Seite, ja.
Und wenn die jetzt auch noch anfangen, also wir haben schon, wir haben schon Schwierigkeiten an der EU regelmäßig äh Gehör zu verschaffen, als,
Menge von Menschen jetzt, also wir haben natürlich da Edri vor Ort, die da sehr gute Arbeit leisten und die auch dann in die einzelnen Länder wieder,
reinfließen lassen, die Informationen und so,
Aber wir haben schon als als sage ich mal als Netzaktivisten Schwierigkeiten uns an der EU gehört zu verschaffen. Wenn die dann jetzt auch noch wirklich auf auf äh,
Also wenn der, wenn da jetzt irgendwie die die die starten untereinander debattieren, so, dann kann sich da aber die äh vielzitierte Zivilgesellschaft ähm,
lange Gedanken drüber machen, wie sie da überhaupt noch Zubehör kommen möchte, ne. Also da kann man auch wirklich äh denke ich mal diese dieses Scheitern der ITR sind ja eher ähm
ja wirklich ist eher Staatsraison der einzelnen Player, die das Ding zum Scheitern gebracht hat, als irgendwie eine ernsthafte Erwägung von.
Internetfreiheit oder so, ne? Also es war ein ganz klare Fragen der Staatsräson. Wenn da, wenn die USA sagen, wir unterzeichnen das in der und der Form nicht.
Natürlich auch ein bisschen Meinungsfreiheit ist bei denen ja insgesamt ganz groß geschrieben, aber die insgesamt Idee, dass sie gerne die Kontrolle über diese dieses Netz behalten wollen, denke ich, dass da äh durchaus die die schwerwiegendere äh.
Ich glaube, da das kam halt im Fall der USA, kam das halt einfach zusammen. Also sowohl das ihre eigenen Interessen. Da sind meine hätten sie jetzt,
Wären jetzt sagen wir mal, sie wäre jetzt die Starts-Rason unseres eigentliche Government-Interesse stark abweichend gewesen von dem, was man,
auch so in der Gemeinde äh äh denkt, vor allem natürlich in den USA, wo einfach die Tradition des Netzes auch nochmal ganz anders verwurzelt ist als bei uns. Der Widerstand wäre wahrscheinlich auch enorm gewesen,
Also da ist überhaupt gar kein Konflikt überhaupt erst entstanden.
Aus welchen Gründen sie jetzt sozusagen dazu nein gesagt haben für äh äh die Netzleute in den USA und überhaupt war es halt einfach nur wichtig, dass sie nein sagen, ja. Egal, ob man jetzt bei der Argumentation da äh jetzt übereinstimmt oder nicht,
Würde also die USA dann in irgendeiner Form mal der Meinung sein, dass so ein bisschen mehr Einfluss und ITU und so weiter und stark kann man hier äh besser zumachen
für sie ganz angemessen wäre, dann wäre der Widerstand auch stark, obwohl man wahrscheinlich auch sagen muss, den Einfluss.
Auf die Infrastruktur des Netzes, den die USA gerne hätte, den hat sie wahrscheinlich auch schon. Den haben bloß die anderen nicht.
Genau, das werden sie aber sicherlich auch ganz gerne so beibehalten.
Ja ja, es ist äh ein ein mehrschneidiges.
Auch nicht ganz unpro
wie wir gesehen haben in und kamen ja äh solche Ideen wie das äh die USA mal eben so dot com und dot org und dort net irgendwie als amerikanisch ansehen und wenn da
irgendwelche Sachen drauf betrieben werden, Webseiten, die an dem Anschein nach
amerikanisches Recht verstoßen, dann entziehen die auch mal ganz schnell Domains, selbst wenn die in Spanien legal sind, äh alles schon passiert durch das äh Zahlamt und so und was mit Sopa und Pieper nochmal verankert und beschleunigt.
Ja und nicht zuletzt mega Upload hatten wir ja schon, ne? Wenn man jetzt auf mega Upload dot com geht, dann kommt ja auch hier so FBI, Anti, bla, bla, bla.
Echt, die gibt's nicht mehr hin.
Das ist dieses klassische Ding. Weißt du auch, dass du dann äh übrigens vom FBI jetzt äh deine IP gesammelt wird.
Na dann.
Wobei ja bei mega Upload noch ein Verfahren läuft. Bei anderen äh Webseiten äh gab es Gerichtsurteile in den jeweiligen Ländern, unter anderem Spanien eben, so ein Streaming-Dienst, glaube ich, äh wo dann,
höchst gerichtlich geurteilt wurde, dieser Service ist hier legal und dann irgendwann später die USA, äh die Domain dann auch mal zurückgeben mussten,
ähm und das geht halt gar nicht. Außer wenn man denkt.
Com ist amerikanisch und das könnte gegen amerikanisches Recht verletzen. Also nehmen wir es mal prophylaktisch runter, bis wir es geklärt haben. Das ist schon eine ganz schön.
Unfreie Sicht.
Also.
Das bringt uns dann, glaube ich, zum letzten Thema, oder? Ähm da haben wir uns das Schönste ausgesucht, wie ich finde. Ja.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal, dass wir über dieses Thema gesprochen haben, war auch andere hier.
Ernsthaft? Ich hab's Gefühl, wir haben die ganze Zeit darüber gesprochen.
Na ja, es geht um die Piraten. Wir müssen, wir müssen mal über die Piraten reden.
Na wir hatten ein paar interessante äh äh Gespräche. Ich erinnere mich hier vor allem an die Sendung mit Gregor auch
äh wo wir schon so ein bisschen auch vorhergesehen hatten.
Ganz weich sagerisch, ja, das äh auch so in der Medienwahrnehmung oder in der Medienbehandlung der Piraten dann äh äh demnächst dann doch mal die Kehrtwende äh eintreten wird, die hat definitiv,
stattgefunden.
Sodass natürlich die innere Zerrissenheit dieser Bewegung noch sehr viel mehr nach außen treten konnte, als sie das äh ohnehin schon tat,
ein ja also.
Man man konnte schon gar nicht mehr äh in in sein Twitter-Fernsehen äh äh reinschauen, weil man irgendwie morgens um neun dann immer schon von dem äh
dein täglich Gate, äh gib uns heute äh begrüßt wurde, ja, was nicht gerade wieder alles
furchtbar und schlimm gelaufen ist, wo nicht gerade mal wieder irgendein Holocaust äh Vergleich oder äh,
sonst irgendeine interne Intrige ja oder wo nicht gerade wieder noch irgendeine zusätzliche Piraten Illuminatenloge gegründet wurde. Also es nimmt irgendwie kein Ende.
Diese Auseinandersetzung als solche finde ich jetzt auch gar nicht so schlimm. Auch nicht unbedingt, dass sie ähm.
Tage treten und dass sie stattfinden, das ist, glaube ich, alles,
sehr nachvollziehbar bei so einer Bewegung, die mit so einer äh irren Dynamik auch selbst äh für sich selbst überraschend äh da nach
vorne gestoßen wurde, die vor allem das Problem hat, dass sie innerhalb kürzester Zeit sehr viele neue Mitglieder
bekommen hat, die dann durch diesen offensichtlichen Erfolg natürlich auch tonnenweise Karriereisten äh angezogen hat, die dann der Meinung waren oder macht das so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob das zumindest
teilweise so gewesen ist, sich da irgendwie selbst zu verwirklichen und die daher jetzt auch,
in mehreren Konflikten gleichzeitig steht, nämlich eben auch zu diesem Altpiraten, Neupiraten, ja, wo wollen wir jetzt eigentlich hin? Sind wir jetzt mehr hier die,
wie heißt es nochmal gleich, das Realo und Fundi äh äh Äquivalent bei den Piraten, die Kernis,
und die auch genauso furchtbare Worte, ich mag sie überhaupt gar nicht benutzen. Also, Leute, die der Meinung sind, man müsste ja mehr einer einer netzpolitischen Tradition äh äh nachweihen und diese Themen
verstärken und die anderen die sagen nein wir müssen uns breit aufstellen, wir müssen 'ne Partei sein die im Prinzip in der Lage ist, zu allem eine Antwort zu geben. Ich denk das
umschreibt da mal die Gesamtzerrissenheit dieser Bewegung schon mal ganz gut,
Uns interessiert natürlich jetzt vor allem äh was hat es bewirkt im Netzpolitischen Bereich.
Seine Meinung zu.
Keine Meinungsfrage, oder? Also netzpolitische Wirkung der Piraten.
Stand letzte Woche auf dem Zentralorgan der Piraten auf Spiegel Online, wie das Verhältnis das Verhältnis der Piratenpartei und die Netzpolitik.
Ja, was steht denn da?
War so ein Artikel, wo Markus und Konstanze und,
Wer noch äh befragt wurden, ja, wie hältst du's mit der Piratenpartei Ende zwanzig zwölf?
Mhm. Habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Und tatsächlich waren da einige spannende Punkte drin. Äh ich meine.
Dass ich kein Pirat bin, sollte bekannt sein und äh dass ich sowohl das Konzeptpartei als auch diese Partei sehr kritisch sehe,
gebe ich auch gerne zu. Trotzdem gibt's die natürlich nicht ohne Grund. Und die ist eng mit unserer netzpolitischen Bewegung, was auch immer das konkret ist, ähm verknüpft,
sie wäre nicht groß geworden, ohne unsere Themen, das ist so manche sehen die Partei als Institutionalisierung der Bewegung oder als Teil davon wie auch äh immer,
Sie sind äh im Internet geboren, äh aus unseren Themen und groß geworden. Tatsächlich.
Auch aus dem Kulturkreis.
Ist ja auch die, ist die, na genau, die trinken Klubmate und so weiter und so fort.
Trinken unsere.
Nöten, die trinken unsere Matte und nutzen unser Internet.
Piraten trinken unsere Clubmate aus.
Und die Hoffnung, mit den Piraten in den Parlamenten ist natürlich, dass äh die anderen etablierten Parteien einen nautischen Metapherschuss vor dem Bug bekommen.
Äh und eben nicht so einfach äh komplett ohne jeglichen Sachverstand äh Internet oder Netzpolitik äh Policies, Gesetze zu machen, ohne wenigstens
tatsächlich Damen mit Kompetenz, gewalter Kompetenz auch im Parlamentsbetrieb mal konfrontiert zu werden. Ähm,
Es gab die ein oder andere,
Also ich kann von mir persönlich berichten, dass ich mit einigen Piraten Abgeordneten bei manchen Themen ganz gut zusammengearbeitet habe. Aber das ist jetzt nicht das, was von der alltäglichen Arbeit tatsächlich
an die Oberfläche gespült wird und bei den Grundfragen, ich glaube, Konstanze wird in äh dem Spiegelartikel zitiert,
ähm fehlt ihr zum Beispiel eine Vision der Piraten, wie das Netz in fünf Jahren aussehen sollte. Äh und da gibt's auch Kritik von Markus und so. Natürlich,
sind wir erstmal eher äh solidarisch als mit anderen Parteien und weil wir da vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Heißt in fünf Jahren, wie weit man in fünf Jahren gekommen sein sollte oder wie es heute sein sollte eigentlich.
Das Netz so.
Eher so eine, ich glaube, ist wirklich die Grundvision, ja. Also so die eine.
Es ist so ein bisschen wie mit der Antwort auf die Frage nach dem Leben, dem Universum und allem, also alle glauben äh schont irgendwie über dasselbe nachzudenken, aber keiner weiß genau, wie die Frage formuliert ist.
Aber da haben wir die Antwort. Tatsächlich ähm.
In der letzten Sendung, in der ich hier, ähm, die wir auch über die Piraten geredet haben, war da gerade das Thema Urheberrecht aktuell. Und ich meine, das hatten wir ja vorhin auch mal kurz anklingen lassen in der ganzen Urheberrechtsdiskussion. Eigentlich,
stehen die Piraten für eine,
radikale Position in der ganzen Urheberrechtsdebatte, die ihnen von eben Medien äh und anderen zugeschrieben wird
Wie sie so, aber nicht geliefert haben. Es gab da das ein oder andere Papier, was dann mehr oder weniger gut an äh existierenden Paragrafen herumgedreht hat. Aber so,
leider ausgeblieben,
gerade du Tim kannst dich noch sehr gut erinnern an die ganzen,
CRE zum nach dem Pirate und als sich die Piratenbewegung überhaupt gegründet hat. Das war halt, wir sind. Die Pirate UK äh sponsert jetzt Domains und vielleicht sogar IPs an die äh äh an die Pirate Bay.
Kannst du dir das in Deutschland vorstellen?
Genau.
Und da fehlt halt
in dieser ganzen Netzcommunity, was auch immer, äh genau das ist, aber eben so ein bisschen langsam auch in der Öffentlichkeit, äh die große Vision für die Kernpolitikbereiche, mit denen sie mal angetreten sind.
Ich denke der Partei fehlt es einfach überhaupt.
Noch an innerer Selbstfindung. Also es gibt da einfach äh das ist halt mittlerweile einfach eine Gruppe von Leuten, die nicht mehr diese Homogenität ausstrahlen und einfach auch nicht verkörpern
mit der sich das mal gegründet hat, ja? Diese Uhr, Selbstverständnis mit wir sind hier aus dem Netz geboren, ist mittlerweile um eine
Vielzahl an Leuten, die aus ganz anderen Kontexten dazugestoßen sind, aus ganz anderen Gründen sich dort breit machen. Klar, irgendwie wir benutzen so ein bisschen das Internet, das ist schon so ein Ding, aber schon bei solchen grundlegenden Sachen wie
wir finden nochmal unsere Beschlüsse im Netz, gibt's ja schon so diametral
gegenüberstehende Grundauffassung da drüber wie man damit umzugehen hat, dass da einfach das Spiel noch nicht beendet ist. Also für mich sind die Piraten derzeit einfach weitgehend noch funktionsfrei, weil sie einfach im Wesentlichen noch in einer Selbstfindung
Debatte gefangen sind und das wird sicherlich auch noch eine Weile.
So weitergehen mit den geringen Ausnahme vielleicht hier der Berliner Fraktion,
eingeschränkten Maße sicherlich auch die Fraktionen in anderen Landtagen, wo sie hineingewählt wurden,
wo auch der Druck besteht, sich auch wirklich an einen realen Prozess
mit äh einzuklinken und erst der wird dann auch dazu führen, dass äh die Sache konkret wird, weil der Rest ist einfach im Wesentlichen so ein wünsch dir was, äh äh.
Level, ja? Wo ähm jetzt einfach mal freigefightet wird und auch gut draufgehalten wird.
Also ich, also inhaltlich das Ding, also ich denke, was ihr was ihr inhaltlich sagt, ist, ist erstmal so zutreffend und richtig. Ähm,
Denke aber, wo woher kommt das? Ja, also was ist der, was ist der Grund dafür und was ich meine bei der Piratenpartei zu beobachten,
ist, dass sie sich gerade mit einer, mit einer Werft und einem Elan da wirklich selber so was von lächerlich machen, gegenseitig.
Also allein gestern gab's auf äh dem Blog äh Popcornpiraten
bei dem ich selten die Artikel lese, aber immer die Überschriften und vor allem zähle, wie viele Artikel es pro Tag gibt. Ja, drei Artikel gestern allein bei Popcornpiraten. Das ist also das Blog, was alles sammelt, was an den Piraten äh blamabel ist. Ähm.
Finde ich äh finde ich also sehr amüsant, wie die sich da alle gegenseitig äh fertigmachen. Man merkt, dass da jetzt ähm also die Partei leidet relativ offensichtlich unter einigen Schreihälsen,
ähm die also da inhaltlich die Arbeit nur wenig voranbringen. Man bemerkt, dass einige Personen sich offensichtlich gerade so darauf ausrichten
dass ja bald eine Bundestagswahl ansteht und die einzelnen Bundesländer da Listen aufstellen müssen, werden müssen oder werden mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Leute da in
in letzter Zeit bei ihrem Handeln sehr auf äh Öffentlichkeit bedacht sind. Und darauf irgendwie einen Platz auf diesen Listen zu ergattern. Das sind alles Phänomene,
die ähm relativ.
Immanent sind in dem System, eine Partei zu sein, die aber trotzdem bei einer Partei, die angetreten ist, um anders zu sein, dann ähm.
Erstmal relativ befremdlich wirken.
Auch dann relativ enttäuschend sind für Personen, die sagen, ich habe diese Partei unterstützt oder gewählt, weil ich wollte, dass die anders sind,
dass da dass der der dass da Inhalte regieren. Und ich bin persönlich bei der Betrachtung der Piraten einfach,
enorm enttäuscht, wie die sich jeden Tag gegenseitig irgendwie äh in gegenseitig in den Karren fahren,
Also ich würde jeder Partei, jedem Gegner, der Piraten,
einfach nur dazu raten, äußere dich nicht zu denen, die zerlegen sich schon selber, äh lass Spiegel online und die Piraten das Thema äh erledigen so. Das äh finde ich es tut mir weh, dass ich das jeden Tag zu sehen,
Jugendorganisation,
die hat, von der habe ich noch nie irgendwas gehört, was die jemals gemacht hätte, bis die jetzt irgendwann angefangen hat, dem Alex Morland irgendwie an den Karren zu pissen, weil der seine äh weil er seine Nebeneinkünfte nicht veröffentlichen möchte. Also äh,
die sind den ganzen Tag nur noch damit beschäftigt, sich gegenseitig fertig zu machen. Und das finde ich echt ähm also und,
Das kann ich äh kann ich mir kaum noch ansehen. Also wirklich, finde ich, finde ich ganz ganz äh dramatisch, was da was da stattfindet.
Die sich da alle gegenseitig zanken und eine Blamage nach der anderen auf Spiegel online landet.
Ja, wie ich sagte, ne, die Selbstfindung ist da einfach in vollem äh Gange und es wird einfach mit harten Bandagen da äh gefightet, darum, wer da eigentlich wirklich den Ton angibt.
Naja, ich muss noch mal Vokapos äh Diabolo spielen, denn vielleicht ist es auch so, dass diese Prozesse,
die wir auf Popcorn und Piraten und Spiegel Online lesen können. In jeder Partei existieren,
nur in den Piraten, die alle über Listen, wo eben jeder nachlesen kann und überhaupt Twitter,
kommunizieren und sowieso eine äh
Listen, Diskussionskultur äh schon etabliert ist, dass die vielleicht besonders sichtbar zu Tage tritt
was natürlich für die Außenwirkung nicht gerade vorteilhaft ist, aber vielleicht gibt's das ja auch woanders und nur bei den Piraten ist das roh und ungefiltert.
Ja gut, aber es ist sicherlich bei den anderen Parteien nicht zwangsläufig nicht in dem selben Maße, weil,
die Dinge natürlich schon viel besser wegsortiert sind. Also da gibt es natürlich auch Verteilungskämpfe, aber die sind äh äh sehr viel reduzierter.
Einfach, weil das meiste eben schon aus Bald sowas ist. Ich meine, die Grünen haben auch ihre Kämpfe äh gehabt. Die wurden ja auch in einer Teilöffentlichkeit äh lange Zeit geführt und es war auch lange Zeit äh den Medien ein großer Spaß äh das eben dann auch äh entsprechend zu porträtieren, so sie dann ähm Zugang
zu diesen Prozessen in irgendeiner Form hatten. Ähm ja und ich glaube auch gar nicht mal, dass das unbedingt was Schlechtes sein muss
Also so sehr mich das auch äh teilweise langweilt und äh frustriert wissen wir nicht, was das Ergebnis davon ist.
Also es kann sehr wohl sein
dass am Ende äh dieses ganzen Prozesses einfach aus so einer Frustration heraus, weil ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt dem Piraten da sehr viel anders geht als dir Linus, ja? Ähm dass sie dann auch irgendwann einfach sagen, so jetzt wählen wir einfach die ganzen Penner äh,
ja und äh jetzt wissen wir auch am Ende dieser ganzen Debatte, wer hier irgendwie noch einen klaren Kopf hat und es auch wirklich nach vorne bringt,
Und dann geht's mit diesen Leuten auch weiter. Ob das jetzt schon im Januar irgendwie sich manifestiert, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich denke halt tatsächlich, dass die Piratenpartei ähm inzwischen auf geistig normale Menschen eine sehr abschreckende Wirkung hat und äh
also dass jemand, der jetzt ernsthaft sich in der Politik engagieren möchte, der so, sage ich ganz, sehr wirklich aus einer aus einer inhaltlichen Motivation in die Politik geht,
sich jetzt,
sicherlich am Ende des Jahres zweitausendzwölf weniger angezogen fühlt von der Piratenpartei, als er es vielleicht zu Beginn des Jahres äh getan haben mag.
Zweifel, weil das war ja auch total überdreht, die Wahrnehmung, ja, also so als die finale Antwort äh auf das Demokratieproblem et cetera äh also mit den ganzen Lobliedern im Rücken, das ist kein Wunder, dass die da auch alle total durchdrehen.
Ja, es ist richtig, aber es ist halt eine Partei, ist also die muss halt, Partei muss Partei sein und muss irgendwie ihren Kram da machen. Die haben sich eine Aufgabe ausgesetzt und dann natürlich haben die diese internen Prozesse, aber ich glaube, dass,
Also ich ich kann's ja, ich ich beobachte es, wie gesagt, einfach nur schau da hin und und schütteln mit dem Kopf und finde das alles ganz fürchterlich. Ähm.
Kann mir erklären, wie diese Phänomene zustande kommen,
ich kann das auch entschuldigen. Und es ist sicherlich auch was was du gerade schon ansprachst Andre, diese diese Selbstboulevadisierung, die diese Partei oder die Mitglieder dieser Partei da betreiben,
Ähm ist vielleicht auch einfach das ein,
Wo die Partei ihrer Zeit voraus ist, wo es eben einfach viel mehr Öffentlichkeit, viel mehr Transparenz gibt,
ähm genießen diese äh und nutzen diese natürlich auch die Leute, äh die dann mit nix Vernünftiges äh anzufangen wissen und ähm
kehren dann da innere Konflikte nach außen und ähm.
Gut, ich meine, die Frage ist, worauf konzentriert man sich, ja? Also bei für mich ist zum Beispiel bei der Beobachtung äh der Piraten,
ist für mich jetzt zum Beispiel viel, viel, viel interessanter, wie die jetzt hier in Berlin diesen,
BER Untersuchungsausschuss bekommen, weil da findet auch tatsächlich viel,
statt. Ja, da wird irgendwie gecroud. Wird äh da wird sehr viele Dokumente, sehr öffentlich gemacht. Ja, also an der Stelle wird tatsächlich diese Transparenz,
gelebt. Da wird nicht viel drüber geredet. Das findet einfach so statt.
Also durch Zufall ist einfach genau der größte Skandal, den irgendwie Berlin jetzt hier äh gehabt hat in den letzten Jahren,
liegt äh in den Händen der Piraten und wird äh wie ich finde, bisher von dem Martin Digious, der auch sehr gut moderiert,
man nutzt alle Möglichkeiten aus jetzt hier diesen Prozess der Untersuchung eines solchen Skandals sehr transparent zu machen
und äh viele Leute können sich beteiligen. Also da wird eben auch sehr viel mal ganz konkret wirklich gelebt, während alles andere meistens nur Brullerei ist.
Wir reden da über Vorfälle. Äh klar, es ist irgendwie alles doof mit anzuschauen,
Aber diese Partei ist an diesen, an vielen Stellen, wo viel geschrien wird, einfach auch in keinerlei Verantwortung, in keinerlei äh Prozess wirklich eingebunden, sondern es handelt sich hier einfach um ein Basisgeschehen, auf das man sich konzentriert, einfach mangels anderer
Einbindung. Dort will diese Einbindung existieren, gibt sicherlich auch das ein oder andere äh zu beklagen, ja, ob es jetzt hier äh NPD äh
äh in Schleswig-Holstein äh ist oder kritische Kommentare von anderen ähm Abgeordneten Nordrhein-Westfalen,
Das sind Kleinigkeiten. Wichtig ist letzten Endes, was wird was wird eben tatsächlich umgesetzt und was wird in den wirklich wichtigen Prozessen getan und gelebt?
Da bin ich absolut deiner Meinung. Bin ich absolut deiner Meinung? Schreib nur keine Sau drüber.
Naja gut, aber das ist ein Wahrnehmungsproblem und das hat auch mehr mit uns und unserer Wahrnehmung zu tun, als mit dem äh das können die Piraten nicht steuern.
Ich will.
Beliebig.
Nicht beliebig.
Ich bin jetzt gerade, ich habe mal Delius einfach mal als Suchwort für den äh für den Untersuchungsausschuss zum BER Flughafen jetzt bei der Spiegel Onlinesuche eingegeben.
Zehn Tage
her, dass dieser Name da gefallen ist und davor ist es dann nochmal irgendwie vierzehn Tage, ja, während die drei Piraten äh blamiartikel am Tag schreiben, ist das einfach medial unterrepräsentiert. Meine These ist ja einfach nur
durch das Bild, was die Piratenpartei in den Medien abgibt, ähm schränkt sie seriöses äh äh Personal ab.
Ja gut, aber es kann nicht mehr gemacht werden, als an den richtigen Stellen das Richtige zu tun.
Ich nehme mal ein Beispiel, Udo Fetter.
Gibt bekannt, dass er äh für diese Partei kandidieren möchte und den fällt ein, der kriegen die so eine prominente Person und den fällt nichts anderes ein, als den mit als den irgendwie komplett äh durch irgendwie durchs Dorf zu treiben.
Hatten wir jetzt äh schon. Wir wiederholen uns. Also was worauf wir beklagen das Bild in den Medien. Das liegt teilweise an den Piraten, teilweise liegt's an den Medien, ja. Äh wichtig ist für mich, was wird,
konkret getan und äh welche Chance ähm hat das Projekt noch? Und ich denke, die Chancen liegen alle noch auf dem Tisch. Ich denke auch nicht, dass das Projekt jetzt äh stirbt, wenn sie es nicht in den Bundestag schaffen.
Ich auch nicht unbedingt glaube, dass das jetzt unbedingt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt schon so wünschenswert ist
ja? Da habe ich lieber nochmal eine eine Durststrecke innerhalb der Partei, die dazu führt, dass wirklich nur die Leute dort sich auch äh herumtreiben und Einfluss auf die Prozesse haben, die auch,
nachhaltig sich dort äh Verdienste erwerben und nicht jetzt gerade mal diejenigen sind, die am lautesten schreien, wenn die Kandidatenposten vergeben werden,
Ähm das muss man einfach sehen. Oder? Also.
Andere, wenn wenn du nichts, hören die Leute das nicht.
Ja, mir sind jetzt viele Punkte in der Diskussion eingefallen, wo ich mich hätte einbringen wollen, aber jetzt so reministierend ähm.
Wenn andere nickt, dann fangen alle äh Schmetterlinge in China an zu flattern.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob,
ist gut, wäre für die Partei, wenn die nicht in den Bundestag kommen, weil sie eben auch jetzt die öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit haben und jetzt auch tatsächlich die wahre äh Chance haben,
Sie wurden tatsächlich, ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, in Berlin nicht wegen ihres umfassenden äh Wahlprogramms und ihre Versprechens in Berliner Flughafen aufzuklären, gewählt, sondern wegen ihrem Protestpotenzial. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das jetzt,
Durch die öffentlichen Reibereien äh schon komplett erledigt hat,
könnte sein, dass sie es schaffen, wenn sie es aufraffen, obwohl ich noch einige Sollbruchstellen stehe, von denen wir einige angesprochen haben, andere aber auch noch nicht,
was mich jetzt vor dem Hintergrund äh von Netzpolitik org und Lokbuchnetzpolitik interessiert, äh ist natürlich spezifisch.
Was werden Sie in diesem Politikfeld noch liefern? Und da.
Da sind noch einige Baustellen offen, die sowohl Kernies als auch, wie auch immer die anderen äh heißen, äh noch nachliefern können von
irgendwie besteht Grundkonsens, dass so die Themen und Thesen der Netzbewegungen TM äh vertreten werden
fehlt mir noch ein bisschen Konkretes, das vielleicht als Wunsch und vielleicht hilft das ja auch in dem Wahlkampf, wenn man,
solider äh ja Punkte Wahlprogramme zu auch Netzthemen hat.
Wie hast du denn die die Rolle die Piraten wahrgenommen jetzt in diesem konkreten äh Feld der Funkzellenabfrage, was ja nun wirklich Berlin auch unmittelbar äh betroffen hat? Man es kam vielleicht jetzt auch für die Fraktion auch noch ein bisschen zu früh, weiß ich nicht, aber,
Das wäre ja sozusagen jetzt eine Ort, wo sie aufwirken können und das halt auch nur in Anführungsstrichen als Oppositionsblock.
Ja, ist das von mir aus abschließlich nicht angesprochen, denn,
Ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht. Also, natürlich war das eine Steilvorlage für sie und die haben dankenswerterweise, nachdem wir diese Veröffentlichung gemacht haben und das durch den Blätterwald ging, äh auch mit in die Ausschüsse äh gebracht
waren noch recht neu äh in dem ganzen Betrieb. Das muss man ihnen zugute halten. Mir persönlich hat ein klares Statement,
Piratenpartei oder die Piratenfraktion Berlin ist gegen die Funkzellenabfrage und möchte diese abschaffen. Gefehlt,
als,
Konsens der Fraktion. Ich habe da einige Diskussionen gehabt, auch intern gab's da wohl einige Diskussionen. Äh es sind wohl sehr viele Leute dafür,
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt spruchreifer Konsens ist, ich hatte da auch online schon äh in real life Auseinandersetzung mit einem Personen.
Es sind Leute wofür, dass sie dagegen sind.
Dass sie für die komplette Abschaffung der Funktion
sind. Äh ich kann aber immer noch kein offizielles Papier finden, wo das so Position ist und es gibt auch andere Aussagen, wo es heißt, ja, so geht das nicht und wir müssen das viel mehr einschränken
und überhaupt brauchen wir äh ja Kontrolle darüber aber wir können das nicht, wir können das nicht komplett abschaffen,
Es hat mich persönlich ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ich möchte auch äh keine Namen nennen, das sind auch interne äh Prozesse,
ja, das ist ein Bereich, wo ich mir mehr gewünscht hätte, das ist eine Steilvorlage, da da in meinen Augen aus dieser Netzpolitik Community müssen sie eigentlich den Elfmeter verwandeln,
Schultrojaner haben sie auch gut mitgemacht. Ähm bei der Funktion der Frage war mir das ein bisschen zu wenig. Aber vielleicht,
das ja jetzt auf Bundesebene in Richtung Bundestagswahlkampf um eben diese Themen, die in dieser Community unterwegs sind,
dann eben auch zu verankern in einem Programm und eventuell auch so parlamentarisch einzubringen. Ich meine, die Linke ist die ganze Zeit okay in.
Berlin ist das ein bisschen einfach, weil die damals auch äh in der Regierung waren als die funktionellen Fragen gemacht wurden und jetzt von nichts mehr wissen. Äh und jetzt dagegen sind, aber im Bundestag sich auch dagegen aussprechen, das ist die einzige Partei, die wirklich einen Gesetzesvorlag, Abschaffung der Funkzellenabfrage
vorlegt. Die Grünen sind für Einschränkungen, die Piraten, weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, irgendwo dazwischen und alle anderen sind dafür.
Na ja, also auf auf äh auf jeden Fall äh sind die Piraten sicherlich auch im nächsten Jahr hier ein Thema, das kann man, glaube ich, schon mal als Gesetz äh annehmen, oder?
Ja, ich ich hoffe das ja. Ich hoffe das ja. Ich hoffe, dass sie,
dass sie es schaffen, irgendwie Vertrauen zu vermitteln, ja. Also Pirat äh Piraten Politiker werden gewählt, weil man ihnen vertraut und,
Piraten, glaube ich, haben da auf der Ebene, wenn man da jetzt eine Infratestumfrage machen würde, einfach äh noch äh Potenzial.
Dass sie eine gewisse ein gewisse Vertrauenswürdigkeit äh ausstrahlen.
Ja, Piraten jetzt schon ein Jahr in der Opposition in Berlin und immer noch keine durchgehende Internetfreiheit erreicht. Was soll.
Es ist enttäuschend, es ist enttäuschend, ja.
Wie soll, wie soll das werden? Ja, ja. Ja, reden wir über hohe Erwartungshaltung.
Nur zur zur zur Aufklärung der Leserinnen äh der Hörerinnen ähm sind die anderen. Und.
Ach so, voll lies.
So gern und vollt.
Ist genauso scheiße wie Ossi, Wessi und sowas, funktioniert alles hin und vorne nicht. Wir ignorieren das einfach, wir nehmen das nicht äh zur Kenntnis, aber wir sind bereit, äh jeden äh Trend zum Besseren zur Kenntnis zu nehmen,
Ja, ich denke, wir sind jetzt äh am Ende unseres äh zwanzig zwölf Round Ups angekommen.
Wie lange ist er? Wie lange ist er? Ist es die längste Sendung?
Ach so, äh bestimmt. Bestimmt.
Abwilton zählt ja Intakten, ne?
Ja, willst du wissen, wie viel Takte wir schon haben?
Kann das bestimmt runterrechnen.
Wir sind schon weit über viertausend Takte hier.
Ja. Ja, wie geht's bei uns weiter? Linus?
Ja, nächste Woche neunundzwanzig C drei.
Ja. Mach dir wieder Interviews. Wissen wir noch nicht.
Mach dir wieder Interviews. Tag.
Wir nehmen das, wir nehmen, glaube ich, das Equipment mit, ne? Du warst so ein bisschen weniger dafür als ich.
Ja, es ist immer sehr anstrengend auf Veranstaltungen was zu machen, Leute zu greifen. Man muss dann sehr viel Zeit und Energie drauf aufwenden und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ähm,
Ob das so lohnt, da müssen wir jetzt gleich nochmal ein bisschen drüber äh debattieren. Ich würde ja meine Energie lieber auf
äh andere Sachen äh legen und vielleicht auch mal über das ein oder andere Zusatzformat hier nachdenken, dass wir mal ein paar äh Spezials machen, Ansatz
hatten wir das ja schon. Hier der Auftritt bei den Datenspuren, den fand ich ganz unterhaltsam, wer das Video äh noch nicht dazu genossen hat, das steht auch bei uns auf der Webseite,
Und so in der Form ähm,
So einiges vorstellen für nächstes Jahr die aktuellen Änderungen sind eher technischer Natur, ich hab die ganze Nacht gestrige Nacht damit verbracht hier unser
Block auf Vordermann zu bringen und mit der äh modernsten zur Verfügung stehenden Podcasting-Technologie zu versorgen, die äh
die das Internet bisher hervorgebracht hat.
Und weißt du, was wir auch haben? Wir haben unglaubliche äh Kompressionen. Also es ist wir haben äh Opus ist ja wirklich ein Kodex, ist beeindruckend. Opus komprimiert audio auf minus ein Bite.
Das ist meine Revolution.
Du hast ein wenig zurückgeblittert. Ja, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig, aber äh es kommt alles noch.
Kommt alles noch. Ist viel in Bewegung. Nee, aber das ist äh sagen wir mal Lokbrotnetzpolitik ist,
gerade für die Darreichung äh von Podcast für mich ein sehr interessantes Feld gewesen, weil das jetzt wir von fast von Anfang an durchgehend äh mit Kapitelmarken hier äh gearbeitet haben, das Ganze alles sehr schön nachschlagbar ist
äh könnte man sich jetzt hier auch durchaus mal an die äh Hörerinnen wenden und äh mich würde auch mal sehr interessieren, inwiefern das für euch eine
Hilfe äh gewesen ist, reinzuhören oder auch nachzuhören,
Nämlich mal durchaus interessieren und ja, ich hoffe, dass wir das noch sehr äh viel verbessern können. Da gibt's eine Menge äh guter Ideen, die auch gerade teilweise schon in Umsetzungen sind.
Um einfach auch mehr das, was wir hier besprochen haben und auch die ganzen Links, die wir geliefert haben, noch mehr zu einem Nachschlagewerk zu gestalten,
Das wird mich auf jeden Fall im nächsten Jahr sehr beschäftigen.
Insgesamt würde ich mich freuen, ähm ein bisschen Feedback zu bekommen. Da bitten wir ja immer drum.
Zum Jahresende, ne? Jahresende Jahresendfee.
Jahresendfeedback. Ja, habe ich auch bei der Arbeit gehabt, war äh super und ähm.
Genau. Und ähm das ist jetzt auch kein Phishing for Complements, sondern werde auch mal durchaus einen kritischen Auseinandersetzungen interessieren.
Ja, so einfach mal so, so Hinweise ähm.
Was hat geklappt? Was hat nicht so gut.
Hat geklappt, was hat nicht geklappt und was gibt's von der Amazon Wunschliste?
Pfui.
Ist nur noch eine Woche.
Wir haben gar keine Amazon-Wunschliste hier. Ah, okay, ne, dann packt den Link noch.
Ich habe eine Amazon-Wunschliste. Aber schon so dick Staub drauf inzwischen.
Packt den Link noch mit rein.
Nee. Ach so, genau, die Linksammlung, das wäre, da würde mich echt nochmal interessieren, ob die überhaupt jemand nutzt, ja, weil das auch echt immer viel äh Arbeit ist, äh die so zusammenzustellen.
Wäre ja dramatisch, wenn das jetzt keiner, wenn da keiner klicken würde.
Also ich habe die schon ein paar Mal gemotzt.
Zur Sendungsvorbereitung.
Nee, nee, auch so im Nachgang nochmal nachzuschlagen und so.
Ja, also unser Jahresrückblick hat ja jetzt auch einige Seiten, wenn man ihn ausdruckt. In Opus ist nur wenig, minus ein Beid.
Du könntest ja auch als E-Book noch rausbringen.
Genau.
Oder wir machen's wie Julio A Sanchez, den wir lobenswerterweise heute nicht in der Sendung hatten.
Ja, jetzt hast du ihn doch noch reingebracht.
Nee, das Thema, das äh rufen wir jetzt nicht mehr auf. Gut, also ich denke, äh wir haben's, Andre, vielen Dank fürs äh,
teilnehmen hier an dem epischen Jahresausklang und auch vielen Dank für die sonstigen Input, den du uns gibst, nicht zuletzt durch deine Tätigkeit bei Netzpolitik Punkt org.
Danke auch an euch.
Ja und dann können wir einfach, wünschen wir euch noch frohes Geschenk auspacken und äh all das, was man so äh wünscht, wenn ihr aufm Kongress rumlauft, dann ihr seht uns, sprecht uns an.
Ja, da freue ich mich auch immer.
Ja, also äh keine falsche Verlegenheit. Äh wir sind da immer sehr offen für Ansprache und Zuspruch und so weiter.
Ausgegeben.
Und und und gibt Linos ein Getränk aus.
Ja, ab dem zweiten Jahr Getränke.
Na ja, mach den mal ordentlich besoffen. So, das war's jetzt auch. Wir sagen tschüss, oder?
Ciao, ciao. Gangam-Style.